Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten.
Linus erlaubst so eine Zwischenfrage aus der AfD-Fraktion?
Nee, die Debatte hat hier gerade ein halbwegs hohes Niveau. Das möchte ich jetzt nicht unbedingt belasten.
Logbuch, Netzpolitik Nummer vierhundert
13 vom19. November 221 und es sind nur noch wenige Tage bis zum dicken, fetten Lockdown und Panik und überhaupt alles äh das große Deja-vu. Herzlich willkommen aller in unserem allgemeinen Trauma.
Da
Aber keiner ahnen, Tim.
Nee, das äh kam sehr überraschend auch. Fandst du nicht auch.
Eine völlig überrasch.
Es ist ja erst im Juli so prognostiziert worden.
Im Januar hat Drosten das prognostiziert.
Im Januar hat Droste gesagt, wir impfen jetzt die Alten und dann äh kommen also das ist ja aber gut, das sind natürlich auch äh die machen das ja mit Hexerei, mit äh mit Wissenschaft, ja. Das ist aber äh da weiß man ja auch nie, ne.
Nee, da weiß man nicht, dass es mit diesen mit diesen Zaubertränken und all dem äh merkwürdig.
Bitte mit den Zahlen, mit den die machen da irgendwelche Studien und so, ne? Also meine Studien, meine Studien sehen anders aus. Da kann ich dir aber sagen, du.
Und und diesen ganzen Exopotenten. Ach nee, Exponenten, das war's. Da kennt man sich auch nicht so aus.
Ja äh nee, nee, nee. Die haben wir jetzt festgestellt, Tim. Das zum zum zwölften Mal in Folge ein neuer ähm Höchstwert erreicht wurde.
Die kriegen alles raus oder.
Das muss ein Trend sein.
Ja, das ist äh ist eigentlich wie bei uns, ne? Also wir wir sind ja auch bei jeder Sendung immer wieder zu Höchstleistungen äh am Start, die so vorher noch nie gesehen wurden.
Ja, ich ich irgendwann checken wir das noch mit diesem exponentiellen Wachstum. Irgendwann,
Das dauert noch, aber irgendwann macht zwar irgendjemand so Klicks, ey, lecko, funny. Explosiones Wachstum. Ich hab's verstanden. Ähm aber das dauert noch.
Also das einzige exponentielle Wachstum, was wir hier sehen wollen, sind Downloadzahlen und Spenden.
Und Verkaufszahlen. Und spenden und und verkaufen.
Alles andere kann meinetwegen den Jahren vor sich hin äh wuseln äh macht uns gar nix aus.
Da bräuchten wir auch mal so eine schöne Prognose von Christian Drosten. Vielleicht kann der da ja mal was Schönes.
Wieso denn, wie sind denn so die Downloadzahlen im Februar?
Was ich nicht was ich nicht exponentiell nähert, sondern ganz linear, aber einem exponentiell vorkommt, ist der achtundzwanzigste November
Der letzte Tag, an dem ihr noch im Meta-Ebene-Shop Logbuch Netzwerks Shirts, Zipper und Hoodies äh bestellen könnt.
Wenn er sie dieses Jahr noch bekommen wollt.
Wenn ihr sie dieses Jahr bekommen wollt, ja. Nächstes Jahr gibt's dann auch wieder welche und andere.
Ja, das wird noch ganz lustig und unterhaltsam, aber ist jetzt auch schon lustig und unterhaltsam ähm ja, Shop Punkt Metaebene Punkt ME äh ist euer Pfad ins Glück.
Und in ja Zufriedenheit und all das, wonach ihr euch eigentlich wirklich sehnt.
Wohlstand und Internet.
Ja Anerkennung, Coolness, all die Sachen. Na ja.
Aber Linus, erstmal müssen wir auch liefern, ne. Genau. Machen wir jetzt.
Wir haben uns gedacht, äh heute mal wieder mit äh Gästen, weil es äh was Schönes passiert. Darüber wollen wir äh sprechen und jetzt begrüßen wir erst mal,
Adriana Grou und Katharina Meier. Hallo Adriana, hörst du uns?
Ich höre euch, hallo.
Sehr schön und Katharina ist bei uns. Ja ähm.
Ihr beide euch haben wir äh jetzt mal stellvertretend äh eingeladen, weil ihr habt mit zwei äh weiteren Mitstreiterinnen an einem
Papier gearbeitet, was jetzt grade vorgestellt wurde, eine Machbarkeitsstudie und darüber wollen wir ganz gerne mit euch äh sprechen. Ähm,
bevor wir das tun, weil ihr nämlich noch nicht äh zu Gast wart bei uns, müssen wir euch natürlich erstmal ein bisschen vorstellen. Ähm,
Adriana ähm also ihr habt ja beide muss ich dazu sagen.
Gemeinsame Vergangenheit, ne, so zumindest die letzten äh Jahre über. Ihr wart beide sehr aktiv im im Prototalpfand.
Den wir hier auch schon öfter äh erwähnt haben. Ähm ja vielleicht äh Adriana kannst du ja mal was dazu sagen. Du hast den Prototyppfand glaube ich über drei, vier Jahre geleitet. Sehe ich das richtig?
Ja ich bin zur allerersten Runde dazu gekommen der Demodell vom von der ersten Runde war mein erster Tag und damals noch als Projektmanagerin und dann habe ich ihn zweieinhalb Jahre,
Jetzt bis Oktober. Genau,
und äh Katharina kam kurz nach mir, also wir sind fast zeitgleich ähm äh dort gelandet und ähm,
die Begleitforschung äh verantwortet und die Kommunikation und äh hat natürlich auch noch andere Personen im im Produtale Fund,
witzigerweise die beiden Personen mit der mit denen wir diese Studie jetzt erstellt haben hauptsächlich. Äh es haben ganz viele mitgewirkt, aber,
namentlich äh noch zu nennen auf jeden Fall äh Eileen Wagner.
Fiona Krankenburger ne.
Fiona Krakenbürger genau und die beiden haben auch eine Prototype ähm Vergangenheit, also man sieht, da kam einfach äh viel Erfahrung aus diesem aus dieser Arbeit mit dem Open-Source Funding aus dem Project Fund zusammen.
Und deswegen haben wir uns an diese Studie gesetzt.
Genau, ihr steckt sozusagen wörtlich äh alle unter einer Decke.
Ganz genau.
Ja vielleicht ähm Katharina deine Rolle beim beim Prototyp fand war was genau?
Adriana meinte gerade schon, ich habe die Begleitforschung geleitet und das heißt, ich habe mir beruflich angeguckt, wie,
Softwareentwicklung vor allen Dingen in Feel und Open Software-Community es eigentlich abläuft, wie das genau funktioniert, wo die Herausforderungen sind, ähm was da die Vorteile sind und so weiter und deswegen, glaube ich, kann man auch ziemlich gut den Zusammenhang,
stattfand und der Machbarkeitsstudie erklärend, weil dann natürlich immer wieder die gleichen Herausforderungen, Probleme ähm Narrative,
In den Abschlussberichten und auch in den Interviews, die ich geführt habe, rausgekommen sind äh.
Und klar wurde der Prototypverwandte kümmert sich ja für die Leute, die den vielleicht noch nicht so gut kennen, äh hauptsächlich um Innovationsförderung und da gibt's aber immer eine Voraussetzung und zwar, dass die,
Basis, Technologien, die man dafür nutzt, einfach in einem guten Zustand sind und da so ein bisschen anzunehmen, dass man nur Innovation fördern kann, ist halt zu kurz gedacht,
und genau, da warten wir was tun.
Mhm,
bleiben wir nochmal kurz beim Prototel fahren, weil ich finde das äh eigentlich ziemlich bemerkenswert. Also das Projekt ist ja gestartet worden, korrigiert mich, wenn ihr's äh anders definiert so als Idee. Leute machen coole Sachen ähm
im Bereich äh der Software äh Open-Source-Projekte brauchen dafür eine Unterstützung, dass sie sich darauf vollständig konzentrieren können und ihr habt,
aus verschiedenen Bewerberinnen ausgewählt und dann,
Gelder, die euch bundesweitig zur Verfügung gestellt wurden an diese Personen verteilt, damit sie diese Projekte durchführen können. Haben wir das so zusammenfassen?
Das kann man so zusammenfassen, ja,
Beim Project Fund kamen so zwei Sachen zusammen. Zum einen weiß die Open Knowledge Foundation wegen einer starken Community-Anbindung,
genau wie viele gute Ideen es da gibt und ähm wie schwierig es aber auch ist, dass man diese Ideen testen und umsetzen kann,
vor allem die Nachhaltigkeit, dass da ein Problem, dass mit der Nachhaltigkeit kann der Project Fund leider ähm nicht bedienen, aber Wasser bedienen kann, ist eben,
meine Anschubfinanzierung bekommt, um ähm gute Ideen äh für Open Source Software, die innovativ sind,
mit Förderung mit öffentlichen Mitteln umsetzen zu können und das war ja auch das ganz neue,
Normalerweise ist es für mich als Einzelperson oder so ein kleines, dezentrales Team nicht so einfach Bundesmittel zu bekommen.
Das ist so ein bisschen der Hack des Prototype-Funns, der natürlich auch nicht ähm komplett fehlerfrei ist, also Nachhaltigkeit sagte ich ja schon gerade,
Aber ich glaube, das war so ein bisschen das Revolutionäre und äh das äh Bundesministerium, also äh für Bildung und Forschung, was den Prototype zu hundert Prozent,
finanziert und jetzt auch noch mal bis 2025 verlängert hat,
möchte eben auch genau das verstehen wie kann man denn Innovationen eigentlich besser fördern mit öffentlichen Mitteln, weil das kann der Staat oder konnte er ähm,
Falls nicht so gut und das ist so ein bisschen. Da haben sie so zwei Interessen getroffen und das natürlich super, weil dann läuft's meistens ganz gut.
Mhm. Weil ihr wart so ein bisschen Ideen äh Mediator und und habe sozusagen die Kompetenz da mit reingebracht, die halt einfach beim Staat so nicht vorhanden war, aber der der Wille, was zu unterstützen war halt schon da, weil sonst wär's ja dazu nicht gekommen, ne.
Genau da hat äh Julia Kleuber damals ähm lange dran gearbeitet zusammen mit äh und dann kamen schnell,
ähm Elisa Lindlinger noch dazu und die haben mal diesen schönen Satz gesagt, wir haben ein Jahr lang einen Antrag geschrieben, damit ihr keine Anträge mehr schreiben müsst oder halt nur noch ganz kleine Anträge und das ist, glaube ich, so die Quintessenz,
ähm was was da gemacht wurde.
Wäre ich noch hinterher, schieben darf, äh weil das wollte ich eben sagen äh ich glaube der Prototyp fand das auch ein gutes Beispiel dafür, um zu untersuchen, was bedeutet denn wohl gemeinwohlorientiertes Entwickeln in der Technologie, weil das ist ja immer so ein stehender Begriff,
und äh um da so ein paar Paradigmen zu haben, wie das in der Praxis dann aussehen könnte und wie man bestimmte,
logische Entscheidungen fällt. Dafür war das halt auch ein gutes Feld. Um einmal,
an bestimmten Beispielen zu zeigen, wo kann man sich denn dafür entscheiden, wie könnte man das irgendwie besser machen,
muss man zum Beispiel eine Luca abbauen oder was war da der Unterschied zur CWA und das gibt's in ganz vielen Fällen. Das hat Technologie auf dem Markt ist.
Manchmal für Nutzer nachteilig ist und wir wollten halt zeigen, dass man das anders machen.
Mhm. Also ich ich gewinne so den Eindruck, der Prototyp fand war
hat sich eigentlich gegründet aus dieser aus diesem Bedarf so äh okay es gibt viele gute Ideen im Prinzip auch viele Entwicklerinnen, die so gerne was tun wollen würden, nur es fehlt
äh die Zeit und die soll halt dann mit diesem Geld freigekauft werden. Auf der einen Seite, aber auf der anderen Seite und deswegen halt auch von
immer an von Anfang an, auch so eine Forschungsbegleitung, um einfach auch diese Dynamiken
dessen zu verstehen und das daraus allgemeine Erkenntnisse herauszuholen. Sehe ich das richtig, Patrina?
Absolut und da gibt's ganz viele unterschiedliche äh Fachbereiche, die zusammenkommen. Es hat einen ökonomischen Aspekt, es hat einen soziotechnischen Aspekt. Ähm es hat was irgendwie mit der Einbettung.
Äh die gesamte Technologieentwicklung zu tun, die gerade so läuft, weil Open Source hat ja eine wahnsinnig lange Geschichte mittlerweile und man konnte,
Wenn man sich die Literatur, die es in dem Bereich gibt oder auch Forschungsprojekte aus den letzten Jahren anguckt, immer nachweisen. Das,
hohe Eigenmotivation gibt, halt die Communitys, die das betreiben sehr sehr speziell sind und spätestens in den 90er-jahren auf den Markt getroffen sind, der.
Die positiven Aspekte abgegriffen hat, aber viel zu wenig.
Und in diesem Bereich des zu wenig Zurückgebens ist halt noch nicht intensiv reingeguckt worden und da wollten wir einen Beitrag.
Mhm. So und jetzt ähm gibt es ja einen neuen Pfand, den souveränen Tech Fund,
Wie kam es jetzt dazu und was ist Sinn dieses Projektes?
Den Pfand ähm gibt's leider gerade ja noch nur auf dem Papier.
Haben wir ihm ähm dafür schon mal relativ klar skizziert,
und es kam dazu wie's wahrscheinlich so oft ist durch so 'ne Verkettung von ähm,
Zufällen oder oder oder Dingen die passiert sind sodass man da ein Vorstoß machen konnte weil das.
Dass es äh vielleicht einen zu großen Fokus auf Innovationsförderung gibt und dabei vernachlässigt.
Was alles genau so wichtig ist, aber nicht neu, sondern eben die Pflege,
bestehenden oder dergleichen, ähm dass das überhaupt nicht mit bedacht wird und ähm was passiert ist, vor allem letztes Jahr zirka genau eigentlich vor einem Jahr, ist ähm.
Zum einen, dass Trump kurz vor Schluss, was er damals noch nicht wusste, aber kurz vor Schluss ähm.
Open Technology Fund die fanden wollte, also die Gelder eingefroren hat und das Programm wahrscheinlich mehr oder weniger komplett äh killen wollte.
Das ähm kam auch äh bis nach Deutschland durch, dass das passiert ist,
vor allem Julia Reeder auch ähm in ihrer Kolumne äh zugeschrieben und äh den Punkt, den ganz wichtigen Punkt gemacht,
Kann ja auch irgendwie nicht sein, dass ähm das Ökosystem äh international ähm dass dann so stark spürt, weil man einfach auch zu wenig ähm Pfand hat, also zu wenig Geldgeber hat und wenn dann,
davon abhängig ist, was die Launen eines Präsidenten in einem Land sind, zum Beispiel, dann ist das natürlich nicht gut. So, weil dann hat man da so einen Flaschenhals und ähm,
Das ist passiert, dann gab's die EU-Ratspräsidentschaft zwanzig20 unter dem äh Stichwort digitaler Souveränität. Ähm.
Äh da der Begriff ist immer noch nicht abschließend definiert, aber die Definition der EU,
mit einer selbstbestimmten und unabhängigen Nutzung ähm sowohl von individuellen Staatstaaten als auch Unternehmen von äh Technologie.
Ist jetzt nicht sehr eng aber auch nicht ganz verkehrt und.
Dann reichte das eigentlich schon diese zwei Sachen, dass man mal gesagt hat, hier sollten wir nicht auch selber gucken,
in äh digitale Infrastrukturen,
in Maintenance und Pflege von bestehenden investieren können, Gelder da reingeben, öffentliche Mittel, weil wir das machen sollten ähm und nicht nur zum Beispiel den USA überlassen,
und und wenn ihr digitale Souveränität wollt, dann überlegt doch mal was das heißt. Heißt das nicht genau, dass in,
offene, digitale Basistechnologien zu ähm investieren.
Das hat eigentlich schon gereicht, ähm dass wir dass wir da äh ein Stück weit voran kamen und diese Machbarkeitsstudie äh erstellen konnten. Das heißt schon. Das war also ja geopolitische,
äh europäische Bewegungen, wenn die's gebraucht hat, aber ja so lief das.
Genau, also die Studie ist unterstützt worden vom äh Bundesministerium für Wirtschaft und Energie, wie das grade so schön heißt, ne.
Genau die ähm die haben das äh verstanden ähm mit wem wir tatsächlich als erstes darüber mal gesprochen haben ist ähm die Agentur für Sprunginnovationen, die Sprint ähm.
Obwohl das jetzt was wir machen ja nicht das Fördern von Sprunginnovation ist aber nichts desto trotz haben die sofort verstanden warum das total wichtig ist und ähm,
eine Grundlage eigentlich für die Arbeit, die sie machen wollen und und gut für das gesamte Innovationsökosystem ist und so weiter und so fort und,
Ist super, wenn man merkt, dass es dann natürlich dann auch ähm,
andere gibt, die die brauchen gar nicht so viele Erklärungen, die wissen, warum das eigentlich eine richtige Sache ist und warum wir das vielleicht auch schon längst gebraucht hätten.
Für äh Sprunginnovation ist ja eine relativ neue äh Geschichte, die jetzt so ein bisschen versucht auch so äh,
so ähnlich wie das in den USA mit der mit der äh DarPa läuft, ja, also so in äh Innovationen zu äh fördern, die halt so disruptive Qualitäten haben und spielt auch Open Source eine große Rolle dabei. Was sind denn jetzt so
eure also die Studie heißt, ich sag's mal hier voll ausgeschrieben, Machbarkeitsstudie zur Prüfung eines Förderprogramms für offene, digitale Basis, Technologien als Grundlage von Innovationen und digitaler Souveränität.
It's the mouseful.
So ein Titel muss etwas tragen, wenn es in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland ernst genommen werden.
Na klar, logisch. Alles ähm.
Habt ihr gut gemacht.
Hört sich doch super ernst an, so ernst zu nehmen.
Genau, ist also sind 55hübsch formatierte äh PDF-Seiten. Ähm wie seid ihr denn da jetzt rangegangen und was war so euer Ziel und euer Management Samarie?
Also ähm die Studie hat zwei Funktionen. Einmal muss man, wenn man Bundesgelder erhalten möchte, für irgendeine Unternehmung, die man vorhat
erstmal das ähm ja das das Wesentliche öffentliche Interesse nachweisen. Also einmal darlegen, warum man das tatsächlich als Teil der Daseinsversorge,
auffassen könnte, dass der Staat halt auch digitale Infrastrukturen pflegt und das soll ist die eine Funktion, die es leisten sollte und dann eben auch einmal,
Markt ähm aufzumachen und zu zeigen, was für eine wirtschaftlichen Einfluss das hat ähm für den Adressaten,
BMWI ist es wichtig gewesen, da eben auch belastbare Zahlen zu bekommen,
und dann zu zeigen, warum die Produktionslogiken und die Verwendung im Moment clashen, warum das langfristig zu Sicherheitsproblemen, zu Nachhaltigkeitsproblemen zu,
allen möglichen Arten von Problemen führen kann und äh so sind die Kapitel eingeteilt und dann wollten wir eben auch ein Lösungsangebot machen, ähm wobei uns immer wichtig ist zu sagen,
rein Investment von Geld wird nicht die substanziellen strukturellen Probleme lösen, die Open Source in den letzten zwanzig, dreißig Jahren,
aufgebaut hat, aber sie sind auf jeden Fall ein wichtiger Faktor, um langfristig eine Verbesserung zu erreichen mit einem relativ geringen Investment.
Ihr seid wahrscheinlich die erste Studie, die in Deutschland erstellt wurde in äh äh in der der Sachverhalt mit einem Cartoon von X KCD illustriert wurde.
Äh also allein dafür feiere ich das schon, weil weil es halt auch einfach jeder weiß jetzt wahrscheinlich schon, welches ich meine. Das ist so diese äh,
Dieser Comic, der halt so viele Bauklötzchen übereinander äh ja und äh voneinander abhängige Infrastruktur und dann hast du so rechts unten so einen kleinen Miniklotz äh auf dem alles äh wacklig steht und wenn der wegfällt, dann bricht das ganze Haus zusammen.
Das ist ja auch die,
Die Realität. Wir wir sehen's ja auch alle. Permanent gibt's immer wieder so kleine Skandälchen, so oh ja, hier eine kleine Javascrip äh Bibliothek hat die äh
ist irgendwie weggeknickt und ähm
tausende von Start-ups sind auf einmal nicht mehr in der Lage ihr Produkt zu aktualisieren und dann fragen sich das alle überhaupt das erste Mal so ja äh wer wer programmiert denn das A eigentlich ne und dann
Das halt einfach irgendwelche unbekannten Leute, die da nie eine Mark für gesehen haben. Wir hatten das ja hier auch selber schon öfter disku
GPG war ja auch so ein äh Projekt ja, alle reden von Krypto und äh da sitzt da irgendwie so eine Person unterbezahlt dran in seiner Freizeit. Das alles aufrechtzuerhalten. Da gibt's sicherlich noch viele andere Beispiele.
Also ich denke, dass es dann auch vermittelbar oder dieser ähm Fakt.
Ja, wir hatten tatsächlich gescherzt, dass wir doch eigentlich nur diesen Comic und dann irgendwie so rot umkringelt, diesen kleinen Klotz unten rechts Problem.
Und,
dann ne, sollten wir mal Gelder reingeben als Teil der Lösung. Katharina meinte ja gerade schon, ist natürlich nicht der das einzige mit Geld alleine reicht nicht, aber da da haben wir auf jeden Fall schon so drüber gescherzt. Wir mussten dann doch noch fünfzig Seiten,
irgendwie nachliefern, aber ähm ja deswegen haben wir ihn auch mit reingenommen. Wir finden den natürlich super gut und äh eigentlich ist da es sagt halt auch alles aus.
Geht nicht, ähm wollen wir nicht. Also müssen wir aktiv werden.
Zeigt vielleicht eins der größten Probleme auch schon, dass man zum Beispiel bei also jeder kennt Mark Zuckerberg, jeder kennt Erik Schmidt ähm niemand kennt Werner Koch
und Infrastruktur ist halt in den meisten Fällen unsichtbar, bis sie nicht mehr funktioniert. Und in dem Moment guckt man hin. Ich glaube, das sollte man permanent schon machen. Vor allen Dingen wenn ähm ja
das Coden so sozial an angelegt ist und so aus ähm einer politischen Motivation fast Sachen besser zu machen, wie das in dem Bereich.
Was waren jetzt so eure eure äh Ergebnisse? Also ich meine, ihr habt jetzt erstmal den Sachverhalt geschildert, so nach dem Motto hier, Open Source findet statt. Das ist die Basis. Die Wirtschaft profitiert davon. Ihr habt Zahlen aufgerufen und habt sozusagen mal das auch äh quantitativ greifbar äh gemacht.
Was ist jetzt euer Vorschlag, wie wie so eine Förderung ablaufen soll.
Wir haben da so eine wunderbare Grafik rein ähm gemacht in diese Studie und ohne die ist es glaube ich auch ein bisschen,
schwierig, weil man's nicht so einfach machen kann. Hier ist eine Bewerbungsplattform reicht ein und dann äh bekommt ihr Geld. Ähm.
Es soll supereinfach und niedrigschwellig sein für die Menschen, die äh die Arbeit leisten, also die irgendwie maintenance machen und so weiter, aber,
wenn man das nachhaltig betreiben möchte, dann reicht's halt nicht irgendwie so okay Förderprogramm äh Bewerbung Geld, sondern dann muss man,
Forschungsteil wieder mit einbeziehen sowie schon auch beim Prototype Fund äh was Katharina vorhin erklärt hat,
dann muss man aktiv mit der Community zusammenarbeiten, also suchen, ähm darüber sprechen,
sich vernetzen und auch wirklich auf die Personen zugehen ähm Einzelpersonen oder Communities, die man mit der Förderung erreichen will. Ähm.
Es ist ein bisschen so ein es fast schon so ein bisschen so eine Bringschuld und ich glaube das wird öfter nicht verstanden dass wenn man das Geld und das sind ja auch immerhin noch öffentliche Mittel nicht einfach nur weghaben möchte sondern so ausgeben möchte, dass sie wirklich.
Was Gutes bewirken, dann ist das für die Förderer relativ viel Arbeit, vor allem wenn man möchte, dass die Geförderten sehr wenig Arbeit haben, also muss man das so ein bisschen internalisieren.
Genau deswegen haben wir uns überlegt wir bräuchten eine Analyseeinheit die Metrik basiert also qualitativ und quantitativ,
mit Expertinnen aus äh der Szene und so weiter auf die Suche gehen nach ähm,
nach Projekten und nach Menschen und äh nach Software-Komponenten, die die relevant sind. Ähm,
dann wirklich auch anspricht und natürlich das Ganze aber trotzdem ergänzen mit so einer mit so einer klassischen Bewerbungsplattform, weil egal wie gut man sich aufstellt, man hat nie immer alles aufm Radar,
Aber das wäre dann eben nur eine Ergänzung, dass man sagt, klar kann man sich auch einfach bewerben, aber man sucht auch,
Und dann äh muss man gucken ähm wer ist denn in der Position auch das dann wirklich umzusetzen also diese Arbeit zu leisten, weil äh nicht jede Person hat die Möglichkeit,
zum Beispiel aus einem Vollzeitjob rauszuziehen, auch wenn man den äh Zeit ja dann bezahlt, weil das ist ja immer endlich. Ähm auch wenn's zwei Jahre sind irgendwann geht das Funding aus.
Da muss man auch eine sehr sehr flexible Förderstruktur aufbauen und vor allem eine breite Gruppe an Empfängerinnen ähm sich suchen. Einspersonen Community ist aber auch Unternehmen,
da in der Lage sind zu sagen gut arbeiten wir daran und dann gefördert werden,
Natürlich muss man's evaluieren, am Schluss auch, also nicht nur am Anfang forschen und gucken, sondern am Schluss auch forschen und gucken, damit man äh das ganze Programm am besten fortlaufend immer verbessert. Ähm,
weil sonst fördert man in so einem Feld, was sich auch schnell entwickelt,
sehr schnell am Bedarf vorbei und wenn man so ein statisches Programm hat und man hat halt Hypothesen am Anfang, die sich nicht immer alle als wahr,
in Puppen, wenn man dann tut und nicht nur drüber nachdenkt, dann muss man auch noch Dinge nachjustieren. Deswegen genau, ist das jetzt unser äh erster Entwurf und der ist entstanden mit den Erfahrungen aus dem Prototype Fund, dem Open Tech Fund,
mit der Beratung von ganz vielen anderen Pfandern und ähm äh Entwicklerinnen und so weiter, aber äh im im im Testen lernt man dann halt auch erst wirklich,
genau funktioniert und was nicht so. Äh Katharina kann da bestimmt noch mal einen guten Satz zu ergänzen mit den mit dem Forschungsteil.
Genau, wenn ich aus Perspektive noch ein bisschen was nachschieben darf, äh genau wie überall in Open-Source-Bereich,
ähm stehen wir natürlich auf den Schultern von Initiativen, die es schon vorher gegeben hat, wie zum Beispiel
eine ähnliche oder äh die OSSF, die eben schon angefangen haben zu gucken, wo ist denn die kritischste Unterversorgung, was sind gerade irgendwie die meistgenutzten Komponenten
sowohl sozial gefährdet sind als auch von den Ressourcen ähm und angefangen da eben,
Reports zu veröffentlichen, bestimmte ähm Vorschläge zu machen, wie man das dann,
ordnet, was jetzt am gefährdetsten ist und was danach kommen muss, weil ihr's eben auch,
Gibt wie zum Beispiel von Black Dark sind die sagen so in fünfsiebzigund Prozent
der Open-Source-Komponenten gibt's halt Anfälligkeiten. Einige sind äh kritischer als andere ähm in neun oder sehr viel höherer Prozentsatz von Komponenten ist in den letzten vier Jahren nicht mehr gewartet worden und das sind natürlich,
muss man immer ein bisschen mit Vorsicht genießen, weil äh solche Firmen eben auch Profite rausziehen. Ähm.
Zu machen, aber alles in allem lässt sich das halt bestätigen und man muss dann vor allen Dingen daran arbeiten zu,
entscheiden, was jetzt als erstes gefördert werden soll. Förderbedarf gibt's auf jeden Fall. Also da ist es nicht so, dass man zu wenig Geld ausgeben kann.
Vielleicht muss man das auch noch mal klar sagen. Also dieser souveräne Tisch fand, also diese Studie ist sozusagen soll die Grundlage sein für etwas, was souverän Tech Fund dann heißen kann und der dann sozusagen die in der Studie vorgestellten Prozesse auch dann aktiv,
umsetzt, so wie der Prototyp fand sich um das, was wir vorhin besprochen haben letzten Endes äh gekümmert hat und auch immer noch äh kümmert und auch in Zukunft,
kümmern wird, ist das jetzt hier quasi der der Entwurf für so einen neuen Aufschlag, der eben diese ganze maintenance und soverin,
Digitalwelt quasi aufrechterhalten soll.
Genau, es ist die Ergänzung zu dem Fokus auf Innovationen, der sehr stark ist, ähm praktisch die andere Seite der Medaille auch mal mit.
Genau
Wenn man sich jetzt halt, wenn man jetzt sozusagen mal von diesem Bild äh von diesem X KCD äh Comic ausgehe, so würde man ja als erstes denken, so ah okay, da kriegen jetzt alle die Leute Geld, die jetzt irgendwie bisher schon dran gearbeitet haben und dann läuft das irgendwie besser.
Ich sehe es aber, so wie ihr das analysiert habt, eher so, dass es eine Option ist aber oft nicht unbedingt jetzt so direkt umzusetzen, sondern es soll im Prinzip auch eine,
Tiefe bieten, dass solche Projekte dann sich vielleicht auch größer aufstellen. Sagen sie, okay, ja, wir hätten sowieso schon immer mehr Organisationen gebraucht, aber wir haben halt da gar kein Funding dafür, dass man auch diesen Prozess
begleitet und sagt okay hier euer Ding ist relativ wichtig, äh wollt ihr das vielleicht in irgendeine Foundation überführen äh ja sozusagen auch zu einer
neuen Durchführung kommen bis hin auch, dass man's vielleicht auch mit äh,
Unternehmen macht je nach dem, was der jeweilige Bedarf äh erfordert.
Wir haben diese ganz zusätzliche Administrationsarbeit gemacht, zu gucken, wie genau man die äh Zuwendung dann organisieren würde und wie sie genauso an Einzelpersonen wie eine kleine kollektive, wie ein Genossenschaften, wie eben im äh Fall auch,
Firmen an Firmen gehen kann, ähm größere Unternehmen genauso wie kleinere, weil äh da könnte es eine Option sein, dass die Arbeitszeit cofinanzieren von von Leuten, die halt eh schon angestellt sind oder angestellt werden und die sich,
während ihrer Arbeitszeit zu einem bestimmten Prozentsatz ähm abstreamen ähm.
An Projekten mitzuarbeiten und neben der Finanzierung von Arbeitszeit ist es durchaus auch so gedacht, dass man in Community Entwicklungen, Stabilisierung investiert, weil,
Ich sagte ja schon anfangs das ist nicht nur ein finanzielles Problem und würde sich auch nicht jeder bereit erklären mehr zu entwickeln oder die ganzen vielen ähm,
Request zu integrieren, die ihn erreichen, wenn man ihn oder sie dafür finanziert, sondern es gibt halt auch andere Maßnahmen, ähm da zum Beispiel,
Foundation, die Linux Foundation sehr viel dazu geforscht, was denn äh noch so stabilisierende Projektmaßnahmen sein könnten und das hat halt viel damit zu tun, dass es dann,
Projektmanagementstellen gibt, Dokumentierer und so weiter. Also es sind halt immer nicht nur die alleine, sondern auch noch viel Support drumrum.
Was äh das Geheimnis von funktionierenden Projekten sind.
Höre ich mir das so an und ähm
Mir so die ganze Zeit so, okay, super. Äh das ist jetzt hier Bundesministerium für Wirtschaft, macht bestimmt total Sinn, dass die mal so eine Studie gefördert haben, aber im Prinzip ist ja das, was ihr da beschreibt, ist ja eine Aktivität, die
Gewisser Hinsicht auf europäischer Ebene eigentlich ähm noch sehr viel wirkungsvoller sein könnte und äh vielleicht,
besser sogar auf der Ebene arbeiten sollte. Ist das jetzt bei euch schon irgendwie mit im Hinter-äh Kopf oder seid ihr jetzt erst mal ist das Ziel erstmal das Ganze also äh in Deutschland äh umzusetzen, um's dann gegebenenfalls später zu europäisieren.
Nee, das ist total im Kopf, nur eigentlich hätten wir gerne schon gestern angefangen und nicht erst in fünf Jahren. Deswegen wäre jetzt dann von abgesehen,
direkt irgendwie bei der EU anzuklopfen auch da wir ganz zu Beginn viel mit Julia uns auch dazu ausgetauscht haben und sie hat äh.
Bisschen Erfahrung damit, wie das ist so ein Open Source äh Funding Programm aufzubauen, auch auf EU-Ebene. Sie hat ja ja Vosser als äh Pilotprojekt ähm.
Angetrieben,
und sie hat dann auch davon jetzt erstmal abgeraten und gesagt gut, also wenn man ähm mit mit Deutschland anfangen kann,
und da schneller zu ersten Ergebnissen mit denen man dann schneller weiterarbeiten äh kann, kommt,
Dann macht das total Sinn, aber natürlich macht's total Sinn so ein Thema nicht in Deutschland zu denken,
vielleicht noch nicht mal in Europa, sondern gleich international, aber genau ähm wenn man das macht, dann steigt natürlich erstmal total die Komplexität und,
Daher denke ich, ähm das ist echt super, dass,
äh BMWI ähm da auch so schnell erkannt hat, ähm warum das relevant ist und ähm relativ schnell möglich gemacht hat, dass man das Ganze mal,
ordentlich aufschreibt und recherchiert und das jetzt eben in dieser Machbarkeitsstudie resultiert ist und klar,
wäre es eigentlich super, wenn das direkt ähm,
europaweit oder international laufen kann, weil genau, es macht in nationalstaatlichen Grenzen eigentlich nicht so viel Sinn. Das ist ähm auch allen bewusst,
wir ja auch beim Prototype Pfund leider, dass wir eigentlich nur Personen fördern können, die eine deutsche Steuernummer haben, ne, also die äh.
Sind dann vielleicht von äh Niederlanden nach Berlin in einen WG-Zimmer mal gezogen, also so ein Fall kann's auch sein oder oder das aber das ist natürlich nicht also so muss es nicht unbedingt sollte es nicht unbedingt laufen.
Was wir mal gelernt haben ist eine Präferenzentscheidung. Man kann die Förderrichtlinie so schreiben, dass durchaus ähm europaweit gefördert werden kann oder sogar international. Das war eine der spannenden Dinge, die wir herausgefunden haben.
Dass das möglich ist. Also hier ist äh jetzt von vom Recht her möglich ist oder.
Dann muss man's halt so ausgestalten wollen, aber möglich ist es.
Jetzt ist ja äh das Bundeswirtschaftsministerium oder eigentlich alle Ministerien in Deutschland
hat sich ja jetzt nicht besonders viele Lorbeeren für Digitalpolitik abgeholt so noch Bodenexperitik berichtete ähm was ist denn so euer,
Eindruck, wie groß da die Bereitschaft ist, den Status Quo zu ändern.
Status quo ändern, ja, ähm.
Also so in eurem Kontakt
mit dem Ministerium oder mit all den Leuten, die sagen wir mal mehr den Staat repräsentieren. Habt ihr so den Eindruck, das ist denen peinlich oder ähm ist es sozusagen gibt es da so ein gibt es da so eine Gruppe von Leuten, die es eigentlich vorantreiben, die bloß irgendwo äh in irgendeiner,
äh nicht so walten dürfen, wie sie äh können. Was habt ihr da so erlebt.
Glaube ähm und deswegen erfuhren auch diese kleine Anekdote mit dem Prototyp Fund, es ist oft.
Problem, der völlig unterschiedlichen Perspektiven.
Neben anderen Problemen, ne? Aber das ist ja immer das ist ja immer so ein bisschen so ein Potpourri und dann kommt's auf die Einzelperson an und das kommt auf.
Zur richtigen Zeit am richtigen Ort, ne? Das ist, glaube ich, alles klar, aber was ich vorhin mit dem Prototype fand meinte, ist ähm.
Dass es aus der Perspektive eines Ministeriums beim Prototype des BMBF,
dass es da Bedürfnisse gibt und Ziele die sich ja auch nicht irgendjemand mal so kurz ausdenkt sondern die irgendwie relativ lang festgeschrieben werden und dann verfolgt werden sollen et cetera.
Dann gibt's aus zivilgesellschaftlicher Perspektive jetzt bei uns in dem Fall ähm eine andere äh Sicht und andere Ziele und andere Dinge, die schon lange verfolgt werden und,
Schöne ist, wenn man diese Übersetzungsleistung zum einen hinbekommt, dass die dass beide Seiten verstehen, okay warum,
ist das total kompatibel oder warum ergänzt sich das super gut wenn wir das jetzt irgendwie zusammen vorwärts treiben ähm und hilft dann beiden Seiten,
und klar und dann kommt's natürlich darauf an,
dass man da irgendwie auch jemanden erreicht. Also das ist so ein bisschen, ich glaube, das ist immer so ein bisschen das Schwierige, weil wenn's diese Kommunikation nicht gibt und diese Übersetzungsleistung nicht gibt,
mein Eindruck, dass dann einfach oft nicht verstanden wird, ähm was wollen denn die einen und was wollen die anderen und warum ist das vielleicht gar nicht jetzt komplett,
Nicht in jedem Fall, aber äh in manchen Fällen passt's ganz gut zusammen.
Mhm. Das klingt so wie du hast noch Hoffnung.
Ich bin total unverbesserlicher Optimist kann leider nichts dagegen tun,
ähm glaube tatsächlich, dass äh wenn man sich zusammen an einen Tisch setzt ähm ist oft hilft
aber ja ich
In zehn Jahren reden, aber ja, momentan habe ich das Gefühl, ähm es es gibt auf jeden Fall ähm Personen und vielleicht habe ich auch einfach ein Wahnsinnsglück gehabt, aber mit äh mit denen ich jetzt oft gesprochen habe,
ähm die verstehen das und die wollen das auch und das ist nicht immer total easy peasy und äh Zuckerschlecken für alle, also klar gibt's da auch Konflikte, aber man kommt irgendwie gemeinsam vorwärts und das finde ich finde ich super. Also ich hoffe, das,
wird in Zukunft weiter so laufen und vielleicht sogar noch besser.
Wenn ich eine Sache noch ergänzen dürfte, ähm ich glaube ganz hilfreich sind dann auch immer solche
Begriffe wie Marktversagen, die in beiden Communitys verstanden werden, weil wenn man einfach ganz also es gibt ja keine Realitätsverweigerung.
Ähm wenn man in dem Bereich ganz klar zeigen konnte, hier der Markt regelt nicht alles alleine. Es gibt halt so was wie Gemeingüter, ähm Cook,
da mal hin, was könnte man denn machen? Irgendwie damit mit maglichen Mächern, dass mir nicht alles zerschossen wird, was für die Gesellschaft wichtig ist und dann wird am meisten.
So, jetzt ist eure Studie vor drei Tagen veröffentlicht worden oder von war das genau?
Vielleicht auch schon dreißig. Ich habe aber ja, ich glaube drei Tage, ja. Fühlt sich schon wieder sehr lang her an, aber diese Woche.
Diese Woche gab's schon irgendwelche Reaktionen. Habt ihr da schon irgendein Feedback erhalten, außer dass ihr jetzt in alle Sendungen eingeladen werdet?
Ähm,
Ja es gab positive Reaktionen also es ist jetzt nicht so dass jetzt irgendwie alle einem,
die Bude einrennen, würde ich sagen, aber ich glaube, das ist erst der Fall, wenn man wirklich auch Geld verteilen kann. Im besten Fall ist das erst der Fall,
Jetzt ist es ja schon ist ja schon ein bisschen so ein Thema, ne? So wie genau baut man so ein Förderprogramm auf und warum,
das so und so nicht und auf was muss man da irgendwie achten so? Ich meine das ist ein bisschen schnarchig eigentlich, was alle interessiert ist natürlich, was die Resultate davon sind,
und deswegen genau müssen wir jetzt glaube ich uns noch ein bisschen in Geduld üben, einfach wegen der aktuellen politischen Situation, aber auf was wir natürlich hoffen, ist,
man schnell von von dem äh Papier in in die Umsetzung kommt, ne, weil dann wie ich vorhin meinte auch dann merkt man ja auch erst so richtig läuft das alles so, was sind noch die feinen Details, die erst so in der Umsetzung einem ähm,
dann erst stellen und beantworten kann so. Genau, also wir warten eigentlich nur darauf, dass wir ähm loslegen können.
Mhm. Und es wäre dann aber schon im Bundeswirtschaftsministerium zunächst einmal angesiedelt dieses Projekt.
Das ist ähm nicht in in Steinen gemeißelt, einfach deswegen, weil gerade niemand irgendwie Versprechungen machen kann, weil wir ähm eine Koalitionsverhandlungen haben und ein neuer Haushalt beschlossen werden.
Gibt's ja demnächst auch noch ein passendes äh neues Bundesministerium, was besser geeignet ist, ja.
Vielleicht kann man noch im Bundesministerium ausdenken und aussuchen oder so ähm genau nee, deswegen kann einfach grade niemand sagen super toll okay und jetzt am soundso vierten fangen wir so und so an und zwar mit uns das genau das ist einfach,
grade nicht möglich, aber es ist auf jeden Fall so, dass es eine große Bereitschaft gibt, ähm in die Umsetzung zu gehen und genau deswegen hoffen wir, dass es auch schnell funktioniert, weil äh es gibt ja schon so ein bisschen so eine,
Katharina Katharina hat von ein paar Zahlen genannt, so es wäre schon gut, wenn wir das nicht so ganz lange noch liegen lassen.
Also.
Wenn man sich das mal anschaut, Spieleindustrie ist ja äh etwas, was gefördert wird in äh in Deutschland. Da fließen glaube ich so fünfzig Millionen Euro raus, die vorhin schon erwähnte Agentur für Sprunginnovationen,
glaube ich ein Etat von 150 Millionen Euro äh im Jahr so in der Größenordnung könnte man ja im Prinzip auch so etwas angehen, oder?
Irgendwo in dem Bereich.
Man kann auf jeden Fall höher gehen. Wir haben mit Erfahrungswerten aus dem OTF und aus anderen vergleichbaren Förderprogrammen,
gearbeitet, um halt sie erstmal an die niedrigen,
anzulegen, wer denn äh berechtigt wäre und wer nicht und da kann man mit zehn Millionen anfangen und dann kann man's mit der gleichen Personalstärke, die wir da zugrunde äh gelegt haben, natürlich auch noch skalieren, wenn's dann irgendwie europaweit werden sollte und so. Das beeinflusst die Zahlen,
auch nochmal also,
Das wurde aber zum Beispiel auf Ministerienseite auch schon verstanden, dass das jetzt erst mal ein erster Aufschlag ist mit einer Summe, mit der man reingehen könnte und das wahrscheinlich langfristig mehr Geld nutz,
notwendig wäre.
Es ist glaube ich ganz gut, wenn man erstmal nicht gleich vielleicht die hundert Millionen ähm,
bei so einem Thema hat, weil äh wenn man ein bisschen leichter ist, dann kann man schneller anpassen so das also lieber kleiner Startmund dann ausbauen. Ich glaube das ähm das könnte man dann sehen.
Und die Höhe an Geldern ist ja auch nicht irgendwie immer so also wenn man die Gelder hat, muss man sie ja ausgeben, ne? Das ist ja so ein bisschen die Logik auch
Und das ist aber ja nicht Ziel, also es ist ja nicht Sinn und Zweck der Sache
dann irgendwie einfach nur schnell das Geld loszuwerden, deswegen haben wir bewusst ähm und eben basierend auf diesen Erfahrungswerten gesagt, dass erstmal ein guter Start und dann schauen wir mal.
Na klar, okay. Also man kann da natürlich rein äh wachsen. Ihr habt jetzt die anderen Zahlen mal genannt, nur mal so ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, was eigentlich derzeit so an Geldern freigemacht wird, die ja im Prinzip in
vergleichbare äh,
Bereiche vorstoßen. Sprung in der Innovation ist ja jetzt nicht nur Software und schon gar nicht nur Open Source und so, sondern ist ja nochmal ganz andere äh Entwicklung, ne. Ähm ist klar, dass da noch ein bisschen mehr Geld unterwegs sein sollte.
Aber letzten Endes geht's schon auch dadrum, das darauf wollte ich eigentlich hinaus. Wir reden jetzt hier nicht irgendwie über ein paar tausend Euro, die jetzt mal hier irgendwo äh hingeworfen werden, sondern euch geht's schon darum, signifikant hier äh,
Geld äh zu investieren, um auch wirklich einen entsprechenden Effekt zu erzielen.
Ja, auf jeden Fall hm ich denke auch nicht, dass äh.
Jetzt mal so gesagt, Geld das größte Problem ist ich denke es ist eher eben das Problem zu gucken wie wie bekommt man es so ausgegeben ähm wie man sich das vorstellt, so dass es dann die positiven Effekte hat.
Erstmal die richtige Struktur finden, ne.
Genau und das kann man eben gut lernen, wenn man sage ich mal 50.000 Euro bis 500.000 Euro mal so veranschlagt und wenn man dann aber merkt
das äh das reicht in Einzelfällen überhaupt nicht, da muss man wirklich nochmal andere Hausnummern aufrufen.
Genau dann wäre das das unser Wunsch, dass man eher ein bisschen flexibler und agiler ist in so einer Struktur. Ähm auch so ein bisschen Erfahrung ausm ausm Prototype fand, um dann zu sagen, okay, dann erhöhen wir lieber mal. Ähm,
Aber zum ja, zum Lernen äh Strukturaufbau ähm sollte, das sollte erst mal im Fokus stehen.
Glaube ich auch noch ganz wichtig ist zu sagen, äh weil wir natürlich auch vom Verursacherprinzip her denken, das ist ja jetzt nur die staatliche Komponente. Das ist dann die Daseinsvorsorge für die Leute, die sonst eben keine Möglichkeit haben, Fördergelder zu erhalten.
Ich glaube, es ist parallel und flackierend dazu total wichtig, dass große Unternehmen äh eigene Open-Source-Strategien entwickeln und sich verantwortlich fühlen und eben auch selber investieren. Ähm wer sich für die wirtschaftliche Perspektive interessiert, ist gerade,
einem Monat glaube ich nochmal äh die DJ-Connect-Studie,
über Open Source als äh Innovationsmotor von der EU rausgegeben worden, hat auch ein Berliner Professor Knut Blind geschrieben,
und da ist halt ganz viel für verschiedene wirtschaftliche Bereiche aufgemacht worden, was für ein Potential da oben so was hatte, ähm wie viel gerade investiert wird, wie viel halt auch nicht und das sind ähnlich flockierende Ergebnisse, wie bei uns rausgekommen sind und,
Deswegen ist es halt wichtig parallel dazu auch noch da reinzugucken und für die Wirtschaft eben auch.
Weil er auf eine ähnliche Art und Weise profitiert ja die Wirtschaft von solchen Open Source-Projekten wie sie auch von der Wissenschaft äh profitiert,
in gewisser Hinsicht auch schon äh unmittelbarer, ne, weil Wissenschaft ist immer sehr mittelbar, ne, dann da hat man erstmal so einen Apparat, die Wissenschaft wirkt äh vor sich hin und hat dann positive Auswirkungen. Und es gibt ja äh auch dort
Konstruktionen wie zum Beispiel Stifterverband, ja? Wo also sehr viel Geld von der deutschen Wirtschaft eingesammelt wird und über Stiftung wieder in die Wissenschaft reinfließt und dazu
beiträgt, dass eben Wissenschaft gemacht werden kann und letzten Endes äh diese Firmen ja auch,
Vorteile davon dann genießen. Man könnte sie ja auch ähnlich vorstellen, dass ein solcher Pfand auch von der Wirtschaft,
mitfinanziert wird. Ist das etwas, was ihr euch vorstellen könnt oder findet ihr, dass ihr kontraproduktiv, wie seht ihr das?
Nee, absolut. Ähm das ist ja auch in vielen Open-Sour-Software-Stiftungen eh schon der Fall, dass da auch Wirtschaft,
ähm Akteure organisiert sind. Allerdings muss man sich dann auch immer angucken, was hat das denn im im täglichen in den täglichen Entwicklungen auf die Communities, ähm die mal selbst organisiert haben eigentlich für Auswirkungen, deswegen muss man,
auch immer so ein bisschen vorsichtig sein, wie man das genau aufzieht,
Ähm was aber glaube ich schon helfen würde und auch helfen würde ist, wenn wir in Deutschland auch so was wie in Born, also Bill of Materials bekommen würden für Softwareprodukte, damit man sich eben klarer bewusst ist, in was alles und so was.
Selbst Leute, die versucht haben ähm Teil zurückzugeben. Das haben wir öfter in den Interviews gehört,
also nicht unbedingt immer klar wen man ansprechen könnte wer dieses Projekt eigentlich mentan und ähm indem man eben mehr Informationen darüber,
zugänglich macht, glaube ich, wird das Bewusstsein auch ein größeres.
Ja Katharina, Adriana, ähm Linus, hast du noch Fragen?
Ja wann wird alles gut? Also wie wie geht ihr davon aus? Also wir haben ja jetzt bei eurer Clique
sage ich mal schon gesehen, dass da äh die Dinge dann auch passieren. Ja, das haben wir mit dem Prototype Fund gesehen. Das sieht man auch bei, sage ich mal, so dem Heim,
der ganzen Geschichte bei der OKF so und es ist natürlich jetzt super und sinnvoll, dass ihr euch einfach überlegt, okay, was ist das nächste Problem, was wir angehen können.
Und ähm ja wie ihr gerade schon sagte, das ist im Prinzip eine Machbarkeitsstudie, mit der ihr zeigt, okay komm hiermit zeigen wir, dass wir's können. Jetzt äh,
äh gleis das mal bitte auf, ja. Wie ist da so eure Einschätzung, dass ihr wirklich damit auch die Arbeit aufnehmen könnt?
Ja, total positiv natürlich.
Ja aber also der Zeit der Zeithorizont äh wäre jetzt so meine Frage. Glaubt ihr könnte das jetzt zum Beispiel so ganz schnell gehen, ne, dass jetzt irgendwie was weiß ich äh Christian Lindner wird Wirtschaftsminister und sagt ach
Idee. Ähm und dann könnt ihr, was weiß ich, äh im Juli äh anfangen oder wie wie würdet ihr da so die die Zeit einschätzen.
Als alte Durchbreite wollen wir natürlich nächstes Jahr, aber es gibt halt äh Entwicklungen, von denen wir abhängen und.
Man braucht eben die Bereitschaft, das schnell umzusetzen. Wir haben ja vorhin schon gesagt, wir glauben dies da, aber wann genau das dann soweit sein könnte, da würden wir uns, glaube ich, keine Einschätz.
Adriana.
Ja, ich meine, also das das Allerbeste, was passieren könnte, wäre, dass man noch nicht mit dem Fördern leider, aber mit dem Aufbau,
in in irgendwie so Q zwei oder so was nächstes Jahr anfangen von Q zwei oder so ähm was ist das in den Monaten,
dass man da vielleicht anfangen könnte ähm,
Weil man muss ja sowieso, man muss das Ganze ja irgendwie erst mal in in in so ein so was Reales gießen, bevor man überhaupt fördern kann und,
Vielleicht kriegen das irgendwie im späten Frühling hin, damit anzufangen, wenn ganz viele tolle Menschen sich da reinhängen und irgendwelche
Gelder frei noch sind äh so für so einen Übergang, weil der Haushalt wird ja dann äh wird noch nicht stehen und so, ne. Also davon hängt das alles ab.
Aber ich glaube der Wille ist da und wir stehen in den Startlöchern von daher,
es kann losgehen von unserer Seite aus.
Ihr wärt soweit. Okay, so. Klares Signal.
Ist schon mal gut. Wir auch. Wir wären dann auch soweit. Wir können das gut gebrauchen, ja? Wir die Nachfrage ist äh gegeben.
Ist schon mal gut.
Vielen vielen Dank für die Ausführung zu eurer Studie und was ihr sonst noch macht äh ja schon viel viel segensreiches äh produziert in den letzten Jahren. Hoffen wir mal, dass das so weitergeht.
Danke, danke und äh wir geben uns redlich Mühe.
Ja, danke für die Einladung.
Danke euch und viel Erfolg auf jeden Fall, dass ihr damit also ich denke mal, es war jetzt ja wahrscheinlich kein Zufall, dass ihr es auch so zu dieser Zeit dann äh abgeschlossen habt vorgeschlagen habt jetzt zu einer neuen
Legislaturperiode und so, das äh sieht ja alles sehr also sehr gut aus und ähm,
hoffen wir mal, dass die künftige Koalition äh das als ein Projekt erkennt, wo sie vor allem
in der Kurzzähigkeit von vier Jahren. Wahrscheinlich nämlich was Schönes zeigen kann und sagen kann, so guck mal hier, haben wir damals gemacht und jetzt sieht das gut aus und kann äh Erfolge vorweisen. Das,
glaube ich macht dieses Projekt ja durchaus auch attraktiv für so eine Regierung.
Die natürlich nach so einem Wechsel erstmal sehr ja sehr bemüht ist halt relativ schnell auch irgendetwas zu zeigen, wo man sagen kann ist ein Erfolg, hat die Welt nicht verändert, aber war ein Schritt in die richtige Richtung und als solches würde ich diesen Vorschlag jetzt auch äh,
an deren Stelle hoffen, dass Sie's sehen, ne, dass das äh dass es denen auch nicht nur von der politischen Änderung, sondern auch so vom vom politischen Kalkül her eigentlich ein sehr, sehr gutes Angebot ist.
Wenn sie's mit der Digitalisierung so ernst meinen, wie sie immer sagen.
Der Linda bestimmt.
Gucken wir mal, was bei rauskommt. Okay.
Thema.
Katharina Adriana, vielen Dank.
Danke euch und viel.
Danke euch. Danke, tschau, tschau.
Ja, so viel äh zum Open-Source. In diesem äh Programm. Das soll ja ganz praktisch sein mit dem Open Source, ne?
Ist gut, ja.
Habe ich äh schon gehört so, weil wenn man das irgendwie nicht macht, dann dann läuft man manchmal in eine ganz andere Probleme rein.
Zum Beispiel in die die Luca App. So und wir wollten ja nicht mehr über die Luca App reden. Deswegen reden wir jetzt über,
Statistiken, die die veröffentlicht haben und da ist wirklich etwas passiert, wo du also.
Meine Güte. Also die Luca App hat einen oder das das PR-Team von der Luca App,
hat einen Blogpost veröffentlicht, das machen sie sehr regelmäßig in letzter Zeit. Äh die müssen ja wieder mehr auf diese App
aufmerksam machen, komme ich gleich nochmal zu. Die Verträge laufen bald aus, ne? Das heißt, die müssen natürlich jetzt wieder in die Nachrichten kommen. Ja, das muss das heißt, der Smudo muss jetzt wieder auf den Talkshow-Strich gehen und so, ne, das geht jetzt
es geht ganz ja das ist ganz klar so einmal im Jahr ne und ähm so,
veröffentlichen einen Blogpost mit Luca veröffentlicht, aktuelle Zahlen zum Infektionsgeschehen in verschiedenen Bereichen des öffentlichen Lebens.
Das ist die Überschrift. Veröffentlicht am 15. November.
Und jetzt äh geben Sie eine geben Sie eine Statistik aus, ja? In der Sie die absoluten Zahlen.
Von Warnungen.
Die über die Luca App ausgegangen sind. Nach Art der Einrichtung unterscheiden. Also zum Beispiel Einzelhandel, Clubs, Bars, Restaurants
Festivals Eventflächen. Ja und jetzt aber sie geben die absoluten Zahlen an, ja?
Und äh sagen dann im Oktober so und so viele Warnungen und machen dann einen Prozent. Und dann sagen sie also von allen Warnungen sind 10,87 Prozent an,
Besucherinnen von Restaurants gegangen,
Ja und daraus geben sie äh den Schluss und sagen eine starke Häufung von Warnmeldungen haben wir in Clubs und Bars,
Die würden nämlich 72 Prozent aller Warnmeldungen im Oktober ausmachen. Ja, stimmt, also,
sind einmal neunundvierzig Prozent und einmal dreiundzwanzig. Ja? So und jetzt fragt man sich natürlich.
Also wohlgemerkt über äh innerhalb des Luca-Systems sozusagen.
Genau. Jetzt jetzt kommt der Punkt. Jetzt jetzt denkst du dir, was hat das denn eigentlich mit Infektionsgeschehen zu tun, weil,
Infektionsgeschehen sind ja Infektionen und nicht Warnungen, die die Luca App ausstellt. Ja? Aber es gibt was noch was sehr viel schöneres und darauf habe ich die auch sofort hingewiesen.
Du kannst, guck mal, du kannst keine, du kannst Statistiken nicht mit absoluten Zahlen machen.
Weil da steht ja nicht bei, wie viele Restaurants gibt es, wie viele Bars gibt es und wie viele Clubs gibt es?
Ja? Also Sie sagen 19.000 Warnungen in Restaurants, zweiundvierzigtausend in Bars, 8undachtzigtausend in Clubs.
Das ist nicht die Zahl, die interessiert, weil hier völlig unberücksichtigt bleibt, wie viele Restaurants gibt's denn bei euch? Wie viele Bars gibt es und wie viele Clubs gibt es?
Das heißt, die Zahl, die hier berichtet wird, ist schon mal falsch. Ja, also es ist nicht der richtige Wert. Jetzt kannst du natürlich sagen.
Na ja, es gibt sicherlich mehr Restaurants als Clubs,
Insofern würdest du davon ausgehen, dass das ein Faktor ist, der das quasi noch äh verstärkt, ne, dass du sagst, ja keine Ahnung, es gibt mindestens fünfmal so viele Restaurants,
Ja und wenn die nur 19.000 Warnungen haben und die Clubs haben äh achtundachtzigtausend, dann ist das ja ein Unterschied, ja.
Das nächste Problem, die Clubs sind ja sehr viel größer als Restaurants. Ja und ähm.
Das heißt, aus diesem Grund kannst du nicht einfach absolute Zahlen nehmen und als Nenner dann die die Grundgesamtheit aller Warnungen nehmen.
Jetzt kommt noch dazu diese Warnungen,
die werden von den Gesundheitsämtern nach Prüfung ausgestellt, ja? Das heißt, du hast nicht hier einen automatisierten Punkt und sagst, hier,
jemand war da und das ist eine infizierte Person, sondern dass diese Warnung überhaupt ausgelöst wurde, ist passiert nachdem.
Eine Gesundheitsamtmitarbeiterin, eine informierte Abwägung getroffen hat. So und was bedeutet das jetzt wieder für den Unterschied, Restaurant-Bar Club?
Ich war schon in Restaurants, wo ich mit der Coronawarnmeldung nachher eine Warnung hatte.
Und sogar meine Begleitung, eine rote Warnmeldung, wo Kontaktnachverfolgung durchgeführt wurde und wir quasi von der Corona-Warn-App gewarnt wurden.
Aber vom Gesundheitsamt nicht. Weil, warum? Das Gesundheitsamt sagt, na ja, ist ein 2D-Lokal äh Maskenpflicht aufm Flur,
brauchen wir keinen zu warnen, erst recht nicht das gesamte Lokal. Abgesehen davon was ich gerade noch äh äh vergast zu erwähnen, in den Kluß bleiben die Leute ja auch sehr viel länger,
So, das heißt, wenn du zum Gesundheitsamt gehst und sagst, pass auf,
Ich war ich hatte Corona, ich war in einem Restaurant. Dann sagen die, na ja okay, haste die Maske getragen? Ja, tragen die Kellner dort alle Maske in Ordnung. Na gut, dann waren wir den Nachbartisch.
Ja? Wenn du aber sagst, hier, ich war Corona 6 Stunden im Berghain.
Oder acht oder zwölf, ja, dann sagen die natürlich scheiße.
Läuft die Suppe die Wände runter. Wir haben keinerlei Möglichkeit irgendwie einzugrenzen mit wem du wem du da begegnet bist und wem du zu nahe gekommen bist und wem nicht. Also warnen wir den ganzen Laden.
Das heißt, die Entscheidungsgrundlage des Gesundheitsamtes eine Warnung auszusprechen, ist eine komplett andere in einer äh in einem Club.
Als in einem Restaurant.
Außerdem haben sie ja nicht erfasst, Arbeitsplatz, Schule und alle möglichen Orte, wo es eben keine äh Luca Erfassungen gibt.
So jetzt wenn ich sage, diese absoluten Werte zu vergleichen ist Quatsch. Welche Frage hätten Sie beantworten müssen.
Nämlich eigentlich die. Wenn ich an einen Ort gehe, ist meine Wahrscheinlichkeit höher.
Eine Person, die ich dort treffe, infiziert ist.
Wenn ich in einen Club gehe oder in ein Restaurant und jetzt musst du, jetzt kommt die nächste Frage, im Club sind halt, was weiß ich, äh von mir aus 5000 Leute im Restaurant sind fünfzig, ja? Das heißt, ist schon mal automatisch mehr.
Dass die dass quasi, ne, hundert Mal äh oder äh äh hundertmal mehr Leute im Club, ja ähm.
Ist natürlich klar, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit höher ist, dass da eine Infizierte dabei ist. Ja, das heißt, dafür musst du auch noch nominieren. Du müsstest also sagen, ist,
von der von allen Personen, die Clubs gehen, gibt's irgendeine Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass die Infizierter sind mit größerer Wahrscheinlichkeit infiziert sind als die als von allen Personen, die in Restaurants gehen, jeweils normiert an die Anzahl der Besuche und die Anzahl der Personen, die dort sind,
Und das wäre die Statistik, wo man sagen könnte, okay.
Die könnt da könnte man jetzt sagen, wir vergleichen jetzt den Club mit einem,
mit einem Restaurant oder mit einer Bar. Ja und jetzt kommt aber der entscheidende Punkt.
Die Warnung ist ja keine Infektion. Und diese Leute schreiben riesengroß darüber, wir haben das Infektionsgeschehen gemessen.
Ja und sie sie tun das in einer Welt in der nur wenige Menschen so einen Artikel überhaupt lesen.
Dann noch in der Lage sind, denen zu erklären, was sie falsch gemacht haben. Und trotzdem auch wenn man's ihnen erklärt, ja, ich habe hier äh seit
Tagen bin ich mit dem Patrick Hennig im Austausch und versuche dem zu erklären, dass diese Statistik methodisch nicht geht, ja, dass man es so nicht machen kann. Und der,
Der versteht das nicht. Er versteht es nicht. Ihr habt ihn aufgefordert, korrigiere das. Ich habe ihm das erklärt mit den absoluten Werten und den relativen Werten. Wenn das alles erklärt,
denkt einfach, ich mir würde die Aussage nicht gefallen, ja? Also man ist verloren, ja? Ich habe es wirklich versucht, ja? Ähm,
schriftlich so, ne? Ich hab's ja dann auch, ich habe sogar ein Erklärvideo auf Twitter veröffentlicht, ja, indem ich das mal kurz zusammengefasst habe. Ich habe ähm
mehreren Fernsehsendern und äh auch Schriftjournalistinnen das alles erklären müssen,
das ist meine fucking Freizeit, die darauf dafür draufgeht, dass die eine PR-Kampagne für ihre scheiß Covid App machen,
Und noch nicht einmal das Verantwortungsbewusstsein haben,
diese Zahlen zu korrigieren, ja? Also diese Statistik zu korrigieren. Kannst du einfach hingehen. Sagst du dem Praktikanten, der die gemacht hat, sagst du so an dem an dem Wert, wir wollen die relativen Wahrscheinlichkeiten pro Person haben. So und dann kannst du immer noch nur sagen,
in Clubs finden mehr Infektionen statt und diese Aussage kann äh äh ähm in Club.
In Clubs finden mehr Infektionen statt, die kannst du aber vollständig mit der Anzahl Personen erklären und das, was du eigentlich dann dich fragen müsstest, ist.
Sorry, jetzt fange ich auch schon an. Tim, jetzt fange ich auch schon an. In Clubs passieren mehr Warnungen. Sorry, guck mal, ich ich fange auch schon an. In Clubs passieren mehr.
Linus, die haben dich. Die haben dich jetzt äh eingefangen.
Die haben mich. Die haben mich.
Als nächstes installiere ich mir den Quatsch, ja? Dann könntest du sagen, in Clubs gibt's mehr Warnungen, das kannst du aber vollständig, vollständig dadurch erklären, dass da mehr Personen sind.
Und die wenn du da eine Abweichung hättest, dann müsste ist ja die eigentliche Frage, die Leute interessiert.
Neben der trivialen äh Feststellung, dass in Clubs mehr Leute sind und deswegen mehr Leute gewarnt werden, ja. Finden dort auch mehr Infektionen statt. So und dann muss ich tatsächlich sagen.
Diese Zahlen haben sie nicht. Haben sie nicht. Können sie keine Aussage zu treffen. Äh die haben sich noch nicht einmal also selbst das, das versteht er auch. Das versteht der Patrick Hennig,
gesagt, hier pass auf, hat er mir auf Twitter geantwortet, sagt er ja natürlich sind das keine Infektionszahlen, haben wir auch nie behauptet, guckt bitte in den Titel eures Blogposts. Dann korrigiert den Titel,
Machen sie natürlich nicht, ne. So, was passiert, ja? Ich habe mehrmals gesagt, korrigiert das, macht eine ordentliche Statistik, ändert den Titel,
dieser Aufforderung haben sie nicht entsprochen, deshalb was passiert.
Genau das wieder die Ansteckungen, ne. Selbst der äh bayrische Ministerpräsident Markus Söder, der ja sonst von besonderer,
Auffassungsgabe ist, ja, fällt auf diese Falschberichte rein. So, was ich daran lustig finde, ist,
Es ist ja noch nicht am also es ist ja nun nicht einmal, ich ich also ich widerspreche nicht der,
Schlussfolgerung, aber es ist einfach äh also es ist einfach die falsche Datenanalyse, ja? Es ist einfach, die falsche Datenanalyse falsch gemacht, falsch interpretiert,
und das einfach so stehen zu lassen, geht halt nicht. Ist unverantwortlich. So. Inkompetenz ist nicht schlimm, aber man muss sie sich wenigstens eingestehen können und das ist etwas, was diesen Lucaleuten halt vollständig fehlt. Wie gesagt, die Verträge laufen aus,
Die Ampel will eine Grundlage für die Corona-Warnapp legen. Das heißt, die müssen jetzt ihre PR-Trommel rühren und die werden damit weitermachen.
Und die werden das weiter mit irgendwelchen schlechten Methoden machen. Das einzige was mir da einfällt, äh zu einfällt ist also wer so Daten auswertet, bei denen muss man sich dann aber halt vermut,
keine Sorgen machen, dass die mit den Daten, die sie von Millionen Check-Ins äh sammeln, äh irgendwas sinnvolles anfangen können, weil denen fehlt offenbar einfach die Manpower,
überhaupt meine eine sinnvolle Datenauswertung.
Zu machen. Berliner Datenschutzabgeordnete macht sich auch für die Corona-Warn-App stark. Ulrich Käber macht sich für die Corona-Warn-Arnapp stark und wenn wir Glück haben, ja, dann äh schaffen wir es jetzt, diesen Unsinn sein zu lassen und ich wiederhole noch mal wieso.
Wiederhole noch einmal, wieso? Bei beiden Apps kriegst du am Ende keine Daten über erfolgte Infektionen,
bei der Corona-Warn-App kannst du eine schnellere Warnung machen, schnellere Warnung heißt frühere Kontaktreduktion, frühere Kontaktreduktion ist der einzige Grund, warum man Contact Racing macht.
Es ist also ich finde, das sowas macht mich fertig, Tim. Also Leute, die die Daten nicht richtig auswerten, ne.
Das äh und dann vollmundige Schlüsse daraus ziehen. Das äh.
Zurecht. Der hatte ja auch schon an der Uni immer die Fassung verloren wenn wenn wenn ich falsche Datenauswertungen gesehen habe können meine Studenten on Lied von singen.
Na ja okay. Äh kommen wir zu einer neuen Datenauswertung, die vom EuGH stattgefunden hat.
Ja, Vorratsdatenspeicherung, da ist sie ja wieder.
Die die der da gibt's mal wieder, mal wieder ist die Vorratsdatenspeicherung vor dem,
EuGH gelandet und zwar ist das der Rechtsstreit zwischen der Space Net AG
der äh Bundesrepublik Deutschland über das deutsche Gesetz zur Verdachtslosen und flächendeckende Vorratsspeicherung aller Verbindungsstandort und Internetzugangsdaten.
Und ähm jetzt hat bekannt gegeben, hier der
manuell Campus Sanchez Bordeauna, der Generalanwalt des Europäischen Gerichtshofs. Der hat seinen Schlussantrag hier gestellt und ähm
Das ist nicht das Urteil, aber es ist eben der Generalanwalt und damit der am EuGH angesiedelte Gutachter dessen.
Auffassung, das Gericht sich regelmäßig auch in der Form anschließt. So und der schreibt,
so sinngemäß? Ja, also nach den Urteilen aus den Jahren 2014, 216, 218 und zwanzig20 sei ja eigentlich zu erwarten gewesen, dass der Debatte ein Ende gesetzt wurde.
Und er sagt, es ist weiterhin auch ähm hier dann äh fünften Mal, fünften Anlauf nicht in Ordnung, ganz allgemein und ohne Anlass eine Vielzahl von Telefon- und Internetda,
der Bevölkerung zu speichern. Das darf nur und nur ausnahmsweise aufbewahrt werden, wenn es um die nationale Sicherheit geht.
Und zu ganz konkreten Anlässen, zum Beispiel regional begrenzt nach einer schweren Straftat. Allgemeine Speicherung aller Daten im ganzen Land ist nicht gerechtfertigt, selbst wenn es nur für schwere Straftat,
Ende. Ende der Durchsage, ja? Wieder die gleiche Durchsage. Patrick Breyer kommentiert dazu das Gutachten des General
Anwalts bestätigt. Das Vorratsdatengesetz der großen Koalition ist fundamental grundrechtswidrig. Das pauschale Sammeln von Metadaten aller Menschen macht uns im Grunde genommen nackt im System und verstößt grundlegend gegen EU-Grundrechte.
Wahllose Anhäufen von sensiblen Informationen über soziale Kontakte, Geschäfts,
Bewegung und das Privatleben zum Beispiel Kontakte zu Ärztinnen, Anwältin, Betriebsrätinnen, Psychologinnen, Beratungsstellen et cetera von Millionen unverdächtigen Bürgerinnen ist eine radikale Maßnahme der Massenüberwachung. Ja korrekt,
Super. Stimmt, ja. Äh irgendwann äh werden die das auch noch verstanden haben. Ist es wirklich äh krass oder? Also es ist,
der wenn der wenn der wenn der Generalanwalt da schon sagt so hier übrigens eigentlich haben wir das ja schon zwanzig vierzehn achtzehn und zwanzig erklärt. Ich erklär's aber gerne nochmal,
das ist schon stark, oder?
Ist so ein bisschen wie mit der Pandemie auch gerade, ne? Also dieser Papagei äh äh Effekt. Das äh.
Ja, das ist echt, das ist echt ein Papa. Das war ein sehr schöner äh äh sehr schönes Drosten.
Ja vor allem ist es ja auch von dem Herrn Wieler jetzt auch noch mal aufgegriffen, ne.
Hat's noch mal aufgegriffen, ja.
Meint so ja wenn der Drosten hat Angst irgendwie Papagei zu sagen ich bin ja hier die ganze Zeit schon der Papagei.
Hast du gecheckt, ne?
Ja, das ist wirklich so ein ein ein ähm der der Papagei Murmeltierkomplex so.
Na der Wähler kann halt nicht, Drosten hat ja irgendwann gesagt, passe mal auf, ich mache jetzt mal Sommerferien und dann machen wir mal nur noch alle vierzehn Tage, das kann der kann der ja nicht machen, ne.
Tja, ja.
Äh aber damit sind wir dann auch direkt beim äh beim Thema, das ja jetzt hier äh wilder diskutiert wird.
Ich äh also es wird jetzt diskutiert. Österreich hat heute beschlossen, also äh wir hatten glaube ich nein, nein, die haben ja,
Letzte Woche hatten sie schon hier stärkeres zwei, also quasi zwei G-Zwang überall, bis auf Einkauf oder so was, ja äh und jetzt haben sie einen harten Lockdown angekündigt,
Montag kombiniert mit der Ankündigung einer allgemeinen Impfpflicht ab Februar korrekt.
Äh ab Februar im Sinne von im Februar muss dann jeder geimpft sein. Deswegen, also es ist nicht erst, dass man noch mal zwei Monate wartet, sondern dass es jetzt eben der Zeitraum, in dem sich das abspielen soll.
Außerdem viel beachtet war so ein YouTube-Video von Mighty äh also die ähm ein äh die argumentiert hat,
so sinngemäß mit okay, es gibt jetzt hier, wir haben's nur geschafft, zwei Drittel der Leute zu impfen. Ähm.
Der Rest checkt det einfach nicht. Äh die werden dit auch nicht mehr checken und das ist jetzt halt auch in Ordnung äh in einer solchen Notsituation dann eine mit einer Impfpflicht zu kommen. Ähm.
Gleichzeitig, also so, ne, hat sie natürlich gute Argumente für und äh dann gibt es gleichzeitig jetzt wieder natürlich Nachfragen nach den,
sogenannten gefälschten Impfpässen. Und äh da habe ich dann auch wieder einige äh Presseanfragen bekommen,
ähm die so ja können sie hier Darknet ne können sie mal erklären warum der Impfpass unsicher ist ja und ähm jetzt.
Waren das also die Sendung, für die ich das erklärt habe, bei vielen war's im Hintergrund. Äh eine wird,
kommen, aber weil ich dann das mehrmals erklärt hatte, habe ich gedacht, okay, ich schreib's jetzt auch mal kurz auf, habe einen der seltenen Momente gemacht, wo ich einen Blogpost formuliert habe.
Was übrigens den interessanten Effekt hat mit diesem Blogpost ähm
die finden tatsächlich eher Wahrnehmung an an also die wir finden an anderen Stellen Wahrnehmung, ne? Meine Blogpost werden sehr viel weniger gelesen als Logbuchnetzpolitik gehört wird. Aber irgendwie ist es doch so,
Maria Reimer hatte uns das damals schon gesagt, als sie bei uns zu Gast war, ne? Wenn det wichtig ist, schreibt darüber, weil das findet man bei Google besser und dann ähm na ja, also, was habe ich da aufgeschrieben? Ich würde das, ich würde das hier noch mal so ein bisschen nacherzählen. Also
Erstens, wie werden diese Impfpässe überhaupt gefälscht? Zweitens, warum ist das kein technisches Problem?
Drittens, wieso dieses in Anführungszeichen Problem nicht lösbar ist. Viertens, was unser eigentliches Problem ist und fünftens, wie wir dieses Problem vielleicht lösen könnten. Also,
tatsächlich werden Impfpässe nicht gefälscht. Ähm,
zumindest nicht die Digitalen. Ähm und das ist relativ ähm also das ist relativ wichtig den Unterschied zu erkennen. Die Werten von berechtigten Stellen ausgestellt. Es gibt keine.
Digitalen Impfpässe, die von nicht vorher legitimierten Stellen ausgestellt wurden,
So, es gibt aber natürlich die Probleme,
dass äh die legitimierte Stelle irgendwie unsicher ist oder zu unrecht legitimiert wurde, ne. Wir erinnern uns hier, äh Martin Schirsich hatte da mal wieder eine Apotheke vorgetäuscht, die es aber nicht gab. Ja, solche Dinge gibt es, ja?
Aber die normalen Impfpässe werden schon auch gefälscht. Ne, also die Gelben.
Ja Moment, ich wäre jetzt bei den Digital.
Ich weiß nicht. Aber das wollte ich jetzt noch mal auch dazu sagen, weil du ja gerade sagst, das wählt nicht.
Ja ja da komme komme ich sofort zu ja so also ein digitaler Impfpass,
Wenn der in der Corona-Warn-App akzeptiert wird, wurde der von einer zur Ausstellung berechtigten Stelle ausgestalt. Es gibt keine Möglichkeit, einen solchen Impfpass zu fälschen.
Ohne.
Ebenso ein Signaturschlüssel zu haben, ja? Also es gibt vereinzelte technische Schwachstellen, aber am Ende diese Impfpässe in dem Moment, wo du in der Apotheke oder sonst was ausgestellt hast, wird der akzeptiert und alle gefälschten Impfpässe,
sind ausgestellt worden von berechtigten Stellen.
So, das heißt, das Problem, was du eigentlich hast, liegt in der Ausstellung. So, wir haben aber jetzt die Situation gehabt.
Wir mussten in diesem Jahr in kürzester Zeit viele Millionen Menschen impfen und wir haben dann, ne, in Impfzentren, in Arztpraxen und so weiter ähm gesagt, okay, hier jeder kann jetzt hier diese Dinger ausstellen,
So, ich habe mir das mal in einer äh Arztpraxis angeschaut. Dieses also das Ausstellen so eines digitalen Impfnachweises dauert wenn er dir Zeit lässt, eine Minute,
Ja, wenn du eventuell musst du noch die Patientin in dem Pflegesystem anlegen, was jetzt bei einer bei einer gezielten Fälschung vielleicht noch ein paar Minuten länger dauert, ja, in diesem äh Bestandssystem. Patient äh Bestandssystem.
Aber den Knopf kannst du irgendwie in einer kürzester Zeit drücken. Schreibst du hin, der Impfstoff die Charge fertig. Ja?
Und in dieser Arztpraxis, wo ich mir das mal angeschaut habe, äh da arbeiten viele Menschen,
alle können das. Ja und wenn du dir überlegst
Die Preise jetzt für Digitale, gefälschte Impfpässe sind so irgendwo wird so was zwischen dreihundert und fünfhundert Euro oder so berichtet. Kommt mir ein bisschen hoch vor, ähm aber äh okay, ne?
Und äh,
du wirst einfach bei dieser Menge von Menschen in in einer Arztpraxis keine Ahnung, da arbeiten zwischen 5 und 25 Leute. Ja und das ist eine Arztpraxis. Dazu kommen die Impfzentren,
Dazu kommen ähm so und wie viele Arztpraxen gibt es? Dazu kommen die Apotheken. So, ist ja ganz klar, dass da irgendwo jemand sitzt, der sagt, och weißt du was, den Knopf kann ja mal kurz nebenbei drücken. So und wenn das jetzt eine Apotheke macht.
Niemand wird jemals wieder nachweisen können, dass dieser Impfpass nicht echt ist oder dass die Personen nicht da war.
Das heißt, selbst wenn Sie da jetzt die Strafen erhöhen,
Äh und das machen sie, haben sie jetzt gerade gemacht, ne? Haben gesagt, sehr hohe Strafen. Ähm ist es enorm unwahrscheinlich, dass sie das jemals ähm,
wirklich verurteilen können, denn,
angenommen, die würden feststellen, äh also die einzige Möglichkeit, diese die sinnvoll ist, wäre, du gehst du gehst diese Telegram-Idioten ab, die da ihre die Impfwässe anbieten, kaufst dir jeweils einen,
und verfolgst zurück, wo der ausgestellt wurde. Das machen sie jetzt gerade und dann fahren die ein, ja
Jetzt hast du das Problem. Jetzt müssen im Prinzip alle Patienten von der Praxis oder von
ne? Äh die die zumindest diese Person in der Praxis denen Impfpässe ausgestellt hat, müsstest du jetzt versuchen dran zu kriegen. So, wenn ich aber da hingehe und sage, ja, wie? Natürlich haben die mich geimpft. Ich war doch da, ne? Haben wir auch abgerechnet, alles klar.
Wie wollen die mir nachweisen, dass ich nicht geimpft bin? Machen sie einen Tita-Test?
Viel Spaß. Ist eine angeordnete Körperverletzung erstens und zweitens gibt's halt auch einfach Menschen, die wurden geimpft und die haben halt 5fünf Monate später einen Impftäter von null.
Ja, das heißt, du wirst da einfach nicht hinter kommen, ne.
Das nächste Problem ist die also ich finde das gut, dass sie diese Testkäufe machen. Darüber kriegen sie halt die die Leute, die so Blödsinn das öffentlich anzubieten. Aber was das, was unter der Hand geht bei irgendwelchen Covid-Ärzten und so weiter, das wirst du einfach niemals finden.
Zweite Problem ist, auch das habe ich schon gesagt, bevor diese Impfpässe überhaupt kamen, niemand kontrolliert die ordentlich.
Niemand macht es. So, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass du einfach nur mit einem gültigen Impfpass von jemand anders, digitaler Impfpass in deiner Corona-Warn-App, Koffpass-App oder was auch immer.
Wo reinkommst, ist 9undneunzig Komma neun.
Ähm ich habe da eine konkrete Zahl, ich habe das nämlich mal äh in einer Bar äh mal mitverfolgt so einen Abend.
In einer Bank hat sich die Wahrscheinlichkeit messen.
Sie haben nicht gesagt, dass es irgendeine Wahrscheinlichkeit messen. Ich habe nur gesagt, was äh was da sozusagen real mal bei einem wirklichen äh harten Kontrollregime, was da nämlich gefahren wurde, wo also wirklich mal,
Was da sozusagen auftauchte und das war äh schon ganz interessant. Also es gibt dann so Leute, die die kommen mit so einem gelben Zettel an und wenn sie dann irgendwie einen Pass zeigen sollen, dann sind sie äh schnell wieder draußen und so, weißt du?
Ähm das waren dann irgendwie mal so locker so zehn15 Prozent der Leute.
Geschätzt, nicht hart gezählt jetzt, nicht? Äh also schon so einige, ja, nur digital haben's ähm relativ wenige probiert tatsächlich.
Also ich glaube es war fast keiner in dem Fall.
Mit anderen Worten, die Täuschungsversuche sind häufig.
Ja, aber lustigerweise doch mehr mit diesem gelben Zettel als mit dem digitalen Zettel. Das will ich jetzt nicht ausschließen, dass das nicht auch passiert, ne? Mhm.
Den gibt's auch sehr viel billiger. Jetzt ist der jetzt ist der Punkt,
Ähm der Wert, den ich gerade sagte, war, okay, wir haben jetzt, ich weiß ja auch von welcher Bar du sprichst, äh die Gastronominen, die wir kennen oder die äh Einrichtungen, die wir frequentieren, die nehmen das Thema ernst. Ja?
Ich aber jetzt mir eine ähm also wenn ich einem äh einen gefälschten Impfpass nehme oder ich nehme deinen. Ich mache ich nehme einfach nur deinen, ja.
Und wir machen eine Wette und ich sage, äh wir gehen jetzt wir würfeln ein Lokal, ja? Wir würfeln eine Hausnummer, ich gehe da rein ähm und die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist auf jeden Fall äußerst gering, dass ich abgewiesen werde.
Also die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass ich einfach reingelassen werde, ist sehr sehr viel höher,
ja das Schlimmste und selbst wenn, ist das Schlimmste, was du zu befürchten hast, ist, dass du halt abgewiesen wirst. Ja? Die halten dich ja jetzt nicht fest und rufen die Bullen.
Ja? Das passiert ja nicht, ne? Ähm das heißt, du äh du hast quasi ähm ein sehr geringes Risiko, wenn du so ein Ding vorzeigst. Das Schlimmste, was dir passieren kann, ist du dir es abgewiesen?
Ohne,
aber sowieso abgewiesen, also kannst du es genauso gut versuchen. Ja, das Risiko ist nicht hoch. Und es wird auch nicht höher. Die nehmen natürlich jetzt die Strafen hoch. Das wird ein ist ganz okay, ja?
Aber ähm es wird nicht ähm also die die Entdeckungs- die Strafwahrscheinlichkeit ist null. Die Strafwahrscheinlichkeit ist null. So jetzt gibt's äh
gleichzeitig merken die das natürlich jetzt, dass die Leute mit den gelben Zetteln, für die wird die Luft jetzt langsam eng, weil weil Kopfpass-Check sich weiterverbreitet, gab's heute bin ich aufmerksam geworden über äh den äh über einen Tweet von,
der Apothekerin, die irgendwie äh sagte, so Moment, wo ist er?
Jetzt übrigens auf. Wir erstellen keine Zertifikate mehr. Die Apothekerkammer und Politik lässt uns im Stich. Hatte heute dreimal die Polizei da wegen insgesamt acht Fälschungen bis 16 Uhr,
komme zu nichts, alles bleibt liegen, ich mache nur noch die Schulungen für Polizisten fertig. Also sie macht dann Schulungen im Erkennen von,
gefälschten Impfpässen.
Und äh stellt dann so Sachen fest wie dass die Leute halt irgendwas vorlegen, wo noch nicht mal vorne ihren Name draufsteht oder so, ne?
Klar, das sind ja auch alle, ich meine, das sind halt alles Strategen, ne und ich will nicht sagen, dass jemand, der ordentlich prüft, nicht diese Fälschung auch erkennen kann, aber eine gute Fälschung,
wirst du nicht erkennen können, ja? Und das ist genau äh das ist ja hier genau die ähm die Falle. Also,
ne? Das technisch, technische Fälschung von digitalen Impfpässen äußerst schwer, aber du wirst das Korruptionsproblem bei der Ausstellung nicht,
hinkriegen, ne? Du wirst nicht verhindern können, dass,
Sprechstundenhilfen, äh Apothekerinnen, die halt äh irgendwie anders drauf sind. Ähm gibt ja auch Apotheken, die zum Beispiel Homöopathie verkaufen, ne? Gibt's ja auch. So und ähm da wirst du einfach das das wirst du nicht in den Griff kriegen.
Jetzt ist die Sache ähm willst du das denn
Ähm also willst du es lösen? Würdest du jetzt die Leute ähm also das Beste, was dir passieren kann, ist, du weißt jemanden ab. Gut, dann geht die Person einfach woanders hin. Schlimmstenfalls geht sie mit einem neuen gefälschten gelben Büchlein hin und kriegt so einen gelben
äh äh kriegt einen digitalen, ja? Es gibt ich habe auf Twitter hat auch schon einer argumentiert.
Eigentlich wär's sinnvoll diesen Apothekenservice mal langsam einzustellen, weil es eigentlich nicht mehr passiert, dass du irgendwo geimpft wirst, wo sie dir nicht einen digitalen äh Impfpass mit gleich mit ausstellen. Die die äh ne also die.
Verdienen ja auch Geld damit
äh dir die die Idee auszustellen. Insofern ist es unwahrscheinlich, dass du heute noch irgendwo geimpft wirst, wo jemand sagt, okay, kann ich jetzt nicht klar, Ausnahmen bestätigen die Regel, aber,
passiert eigentlich nicht. So, gleichzeitig hast du jetzt schon eine unbekannte Anzahl gefälschter im Umlauf und die wirst du niemals deektieren können, ne. Es gibt jetzt wenigstens die Corona-Warn-App,
lehnt jetzt gefälschte oder zurückgerufene Zertifikate ab und das sind exakt zwei.
Ja? Irgendwie das eine von von äh von Robert Koch und das andere von Adolf Hitler. Irgendwie so ne, aber das jetzt irgendwo,
So so ungefähr ist das. Und ähm die äh das das wird halt einfach nicht ähm nicht passieren,
ne, ist eine Sache, was eventuell passieren kann, ist, dass äh verantwortungsbewusste Läden ordentlich kontrollieren und dich nicht reinlassen, aber auch die werden dich da nicht festhalten und die,
Polizei rufen. Das heißt, unser eigentliches Problem ist, dass Impfpassfälschung eigentlich einfacher ist als Impfung.
So. Die Papier gefälschten Papierausweise, die kriegst du für unter hundert Euro, für fertig ausgestellte, digitale Zeit irgendwie zwischen hundert und dreihundert. Ja,
hier gibt's einen schönen Tweet vom 15. November von einem Stefan Heinrichs, der sagt, solange es leichter ist, an ein gefälschtes Impfzertifikat ranzukommen, als nach fünf Monaten an eine Booster-Impfung, braucht man's eigentlich über nichts mehr zu wundern. Da hat er genau Recht
ähm und was aber jetzt die entscheidende Sache ist, wenn jetzt mehr Einschränkungen für Ungeimpfte in Aussicht gestellt werden,
dann erhöht das nämlich primär die Motivation einen Impfpass zu bekommen und nicht notwendigerweise die Motivation sich auch impfen zu lassen.
Dir an, Österreich hat ja irgendwie letzte Woche oder was, diesen härteren 2G-Lockdown gemacht.
Und dann wurde von Impfanstürmen berichtet
Ja, stimmt. Also da standen dann auf einmal wieder Schlangen, da wo's Impfimpfungen gab, weil ein paar Leute sich gesagt haben, okay, lasse ich mich doch impfen. Dann habe ich mir das mal bei Hour World in Data angeguckt und habe mir plotten lassen, die Neuimpfungen.
Ja und da siehst du halt, ähm dass hier eben,
kurz nachdem wir das machen Anfang November geht diese Zahl der äh Pargelive wechseln, also der Erstimpfung geht nochmal hoch.
Der Zweitimpfungen bleibt natürlich äh weit also bleibt gleich, steigt jetzt natürlich dann mit,
Abstand von vier Wochen so ein bisschen an aber wenn du diese Anzahl Neuimpfung, die ist halt irgendwo unter fünfzigtausend und war vorher im Schnitt irgendwo unter unter fünfundzwanzigtausend, ja? Das heißt, der
der Zuwachs ist nicht besonders hoch und Peak irgendwann äh,
Ende Mai, Anfang Juni haben die hundert1fünfzigtausend am Tag gemacht, ne? Das war quasi die Anzahl neu Impfung, die du haben willst, die halten, die halt ordentlich sind. De facto haben sie nur diesen diesen.
Abklingenden, gleichbleibenden, ich lasse mich mal impfen, Strom verdoppelt auf gerade mal fünfzigtausend. Das ist in keiner Form ausreichend. Äh ich glaube, das macht dann irgendwie,
Insgesamt jetzt irgendwie haben sie zwei Prozent der Bevölkerung noch mal damit bekommen, dass sie diesen diesen härteren 2G
eingeführt haben. Jetzt wird's natürlich spannend. Was passiert bis Februar? Und meine These ist, die Fälschungen werden zunehmen und die Impfungen nicht ausreichend.
Und jetzt ne kann man halt sagen okay Impfzwang so.
Etwas, was wenn man sich anschaut, dass jetzt hier täglich was sind jetzt grade ein Flugzeug.
Pflicht, ne?
Ja Impfpflicht.
Zwang ist also bist noch nicht so ganz klar, was was sozusagen das Strafmaß ist, wenn man der Pflicht nicht nachkommt, ja?
Also kannst zu Hause bleiben. Nicht da in deine eigenen vier Wohnungen wird dich ja jetzt keiner aufsuchen.
Sehr gut, aber es ist kein Zwang in dem Sinne, dass jemand dann vorbeikommt und dir eine Spritze reinrammt, also das ist äh.
Schon wieder nur so eine Hippie-Kacke.
Also ich kenne jetzt die äh den Erlass, der jetzt in Österreich da geplant ist oder schon durchgeführt worden in in der Hinsicht nicht. Ich denke nur, dass es jetzt in der Debatte da drum.
Wichtig ist nicht diesen.
Begriff zu verwenden, der halt äh ne eher von der Gegnerseite äh verwendet wird.
Hast du absolut Recht, stimmt.
Ähm so, also Impfpflicht, ne. Und da wäre halt meine Überlegung, also genau, Mi T, wenn Kim heißt der, glaube ich, hat äh gesagt, hier ähm.
Impfpflicht ist schon in Ordnung, kann man mal machen, vor allem wenn wir,
einfach in der Situation sind, dass wir denen jetzt ein Jahr erklärt haben, dass die ähm unsere unsere Intensivstation belegen und dass halt eine Flugzeugladung von denen am Tag stirbt.
So. Ja und das sind natürlich schon relativ gute Argumente. Sie sagt aber natürlich auch,
Anders wendet den Anlass nicht mehr beigebracht kriegst, dann muss man eben zu diesem Schritt.
Greifen und sie hat sich auch an vor einiger Zeit noch sehr ähm,
Dagegen ausgesprochen und entsprechend, ne, ist jetzt trägt sie jetzt die Argumente vor. Was ich entscheidend finde ist, dass sie sagt, es ist quasi die Ultima Ratio und.
Ich glaube aber, und das wollte ich bei dieser Gelegenheit noch einmal wiederholen, dass wir in Deutschland uns wir haben viel zu deutsch geimpft.
Deutsch geimpft. Okay, erklär mal, was das ist.
Erstmal die ersten Monate Riesentrara. Nein, du darfst keine Impfungen. Äh wir machen das in der Reihenfolge und nicht in der und,
hier und Booster gibt's aber jetzt erst nach sechs Monaten wäre das nach fünf Monaten macht es äh lasst das im Schrank, ne. Dann haben sie am Ende das Astrazeneca so lange den Leuten vorenthalten, dass es wegwerfen mussten.
Leute, die waren froh, das zu kriegen, statt es denen zu geben. Ja? Ähm und,
dann ist natürlich die Frage mit den positiven und negativen Anreizen.
Und da kommen relativ simple Prinzipien der Psychologie zum Wirken, die viel zu selten berücksichtigt werden. Relativ einfach positive, negative Anreize und dann noch äh dazu sagen wir noch ein bisschen und quatsching.
Negative Anreize sind unangenehme Konsequenzen des eigenen Verhaltens,
Positive Anreize sind Belohnungen. So, für die meisten Leute ist der bessere Gesundheitsschutz Anreiz genug, sich impfen zu lassen. Damit kriegst du offenbar zwei Drittel, ja?
Dann kann man sich denken, dass der normale Zugang zum gesellschaftlichen Leben, die Rückkehr zum gesellschaftlichen Leben, ja, ein positiver Anreiz ist.
Aber es ist keiner,
ist keiner und das habe ich auch immer gesagt. Es ist keiner, weil du diesen normalen Zugang den Leuten vorher weggenommen hast. Ein positiver Anreiz ist nur, was du neu und als Belohnung dazu bekommst. Nicht, was dir weggenommen wurde.
Ne? Ich kann dir jetzt auch nicht irgendwie, was weiß ich, dein Portemonnaie klauen und sagen, hör mal, Tim,
Hier sind Anreiz dich zu impfen, kriegst dein Portemonnaie wieder. Dann würdest du ja nicht sagen oh ja geil, jetzt lasse ich mich impfen, da kriegen wir ein Portemonnaie wieder,
sondern du würdest sagen, Alter, äh komm her, ich äh ich möchte mein Portemonnaie äh wiederhaben und ich bin bereit äh seelische und vielleicht sogar körperliche Gewalt anzuwenden, um das zurück zu erlangen. Na, aber ich lasse mich jetzt hier nicht zwingen,
oder verleiten etwas zu tun, was ich nicht wollte. Das heißt, was du mit solchem, wir nehmen dir etwas weg.
Und wollen es dir dann als Belohnung Belohnung zurückgeben. Das führt zu einem Phänomen, das sich Reaktanz nennt. Nämlich, dass die Menschen.
Quasi ähm,
die Motivation zu Wiederherstellung der eingeengten Freiheitsspielräume anders ausleben, ja? Nämlich nicht, dass Sie sagen, okay, ich ich äh folge dem jetzt, sondern letztendlich trotz trotzig werden.
Ja? Und die Einstellung ist eben dann quasi sozusagen du du machst es quasi schlimmer,
Ja? Also du du dadurch, dass du die Leute mit auf diese Weise versuchst zu motivieren.
Senkst du die Motivation auf dieses Verhalten, was du eigentlich herbeiführen möchtest, noch mehr ab als sie ohnehin schon war,
Also Reaktanz echt schlecht, ja. Was wir kaum machen sind positive,
Anreize und das ist eine der wenigen Sachen, die ich letztens noch mit einem Freund über Behaviriismus gesprochen, ja? Also psychologische Strömung so sechziger Jahre, die alles mit Belohnung und Strafe erklären wollten
Was die meisten Leute nicht verstanden haben oder was die meisten Leute sich beim nicht gemerkt haben war, dass sie gesagt haben, das Beste ist immer Belohnung.
Und wenn du Leuten Verhalten abgewöhnen willst, dann kannst du strafen, aber noch besser ist ignorieren. Ja, das sind quasi die die äh die äh also zusammengefasst die Ergebnisse äh des des.
Was meinst du mit Ignorieren, wer oder was soll ignoriert werden?
Keine Konsequenz. Also keine weder positive noch negative Konsequenz. Unerwünschtes Verhalten am besten immer ignorieren.
Besser als Strafen, weil du ähm weil,
Das ist auch relativ einfach zu erklären. Positive Reize kommen haben sofortigen Lerneffekt, ja? Und das Beste, was du machen kannst, sind intermittierende, positive Reize. Also nicht jedes Mal eine Belohnung.
Sondern immer seltener. Ja, weil dann versuchen die Leute immer weiter. So funktionieren Spielautomaten. Ähm Strafen,
sind beim Spielautomat eigentlich ziemlich häufig in der Regel auf Dauer wirst du da eh immer ärmer, ja? Aber diese Strafen funktionieren nicht. Also die die wirken nicht so stark wie die intermittierenden Belohnungen.
Und wenn ein Verhalten ohne Konsequenz bleibt, weder positiv noch negativ, ist das det Beste, um es den Leuten abzugewöhnen.
Daher ja auch so keine Ahnung, Don't Feed the troll und so weiter, ja? Keine Konsequenz fürs Verhalten ist das, was am ehesten dazu führt, dass du es sein lässt.
Was du machen möchtest ist, du möchtest den Leuten positive Anreize geben, nicht negative. Und eine Impfpflicht ist ein negativer Anreiz,
Ja und droht Reaktanz herbeizuführen. Würdest du jetzt mit Genuinen Belohnungen antreten,
Ja, zum Beispiel äh was weiß ich, was ich letztes Mal schon sagte, fünfzig Euro pro Shot oder hundert Euro pro Shot,
oder wie du sagtest die Impfflotterie. Ich also gibt's auch Leute, die die Lotterie bevorzugen, weil das eben ein intermettierender Verstärkungsplan ist, ne, ähm der einen größeren Gewinn in Aussicht stellt, zwar mit einer geringeren Wahrscheinlichkeit, aber dafür einen größeren Gewinn,
äh kannste auch machen, aber irgendeine Form von Belohnung, das haben wir noch nicht gemacht. Wir haben aber auch hier im Podcast übrigens über die Leute gelacht, die sich für eine Bratwurst haben impfen lassen.
Das andere ist, du willst niedrigschwellige Angebote machen. Also im Supermarkt, beim Festival. Äh was weiß ich, bei am Theater, wo auch
immer in ich war hier in vor ein paar Wochen ja in Wien da konnte in diesem Stephansdom als irgend so eine Kirche auf die die besonders stolz sind ne? Da konntest du dich auch impfen lassen mal eben ohne Schlange fertig ne? Da kommen sie zu dir zu den Schäfchen.
Und diese Aktionen sind jedes Mal ein Erfolg. Ja, da werden also wenn die das machen, dann stehen die Leute da schlank und du kannst jedes Mal sagen, hat funktioniert,
Negative Anreize hingegen,
guck dir das an, was in Österreich passiert ist. Nicht viel, nicht aus, nicht annähernd ausreichend. Und deswegen denke ich, ähm wir müssen halt,
zumindest irgendwie die das Standardwissen der Psychologie, also ne, die Wahrscheinlichkeit äh das das Impfen,
einfach die einfachste und verfügbarste ähm Handlungsalternative ist und Belohnung einfach noch sehr viel mehr zum zum Einsatz bringen,
Sonst laufen wir in diese Sache mit der Reaktanz und das wird dazu führen, dass du einfach nur mehr illegitim ausgestellte ähm Impfpässe hast und das,
wenn du dir äh dir eine Person vorstellst, die es bis in den Dezember 2021 geschafft hat, sich nicht impfen zu lassen.
Kriegst du jetzt nicht durch einen negativen Anreiz dadrauf. Die hatte genug negative Anreize. Und ich glaube, wir haben die positiven Anreize noch nicht ausgeschöpft. Und ich glaube, dass wir aus den positiven Anreizen gerade noch mehr,
zunehmende Impfquote bekommen könnten als aus einer verpflichtenden Impfung.
Also ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob du die Zahlen, wie sie sich jetzt grade in Österreich darstellen, ausreichend äh,
würdigst, also na ja, ich meine, sie haben
derzeit äh gehen die Erstimpfzahlen halt signifikant noch hoch. Deshalb sind es halt ungefähr so 0,2Prozent der Bevölkerung, die pro Tag,
eine Erstimpfung bekommen und zu den allerbesten Zeiten waren's halt 0Komma sechs. Das heißt, sie sind schon auf einem Drittel der besten Phase.
Ja die haben 4sechzig Prozent geimpft. So, wenn du jetzt pro Woche gehen wir mal davon aus, ein Prozent hinzubekommst, dann sind die noch äh ungefähr.
20 Wochen beschäftigt bis sie irgendwo bei 84 sind und 84 reicht immer noch nicht aus.
Ja ich weiß nicht, ob man das jetzt so rechnen kann. Also ich meine äh vor einem Monat war waren sie bei 0,04% pro Tag. Jetzt sind sie halt bei 0,2% pro Tag. Das heißt, sie haben eine Verfünffachung der Erstimpfung,
und äh da ist jetzt ein ganz kleiner,
nach unten die letzten zwei Tage, aber das ist jetzt also äh kein kein sichtbarer, deutlicher Trend. Also es kann auch sein, dass es
weiter hoch geht. Also derzeit geht es seit einem Monat geht es hoch und in Deutschland wäre das halt äh dann doch schon mal ganz äh schön, wenn wir äh in solche Bereiche überhaupt,
vorstoßen würden. Da sind wir nämlich jetzt gerade bei null Komma null fünf Prozent.
Aber meine These ist nicht, dass die nicht steigen. Meine These ist, dass die Motivation zur Fälschung stärker steigt.
Ja gut, das mag ja alles sein.
Ich äh ja aber ich wollte jetzt nur mal den weißt du wir kriegen das ja dann gleich in den Kommentaren sowieso äh wieder unter die Nase gerieben. Also ich sehe
es sozusagen jetzt einfach von den nackt
Zahlen her äh so. Es lässt sich derzeit noch nicht so richtig sagen, wie das mit der Impfung in Österreich sich jetzt wirklich entwickelt, aber es ist definitiv so, dass seitdem die Ansagen stärker werden, die Bereitschaft äh steigt, ob's ausreicht. Das ist eine ganz andere Sache.
Also es ist nicht ausreichend.
Es ist ein ich glaube es ist ein klarer Fakt dass die Motivation zur Fälschung im Moment stärker steigt als die Motivation zur Impfung,
und dem kannst du entgegentreten mit relativ einfachem psychologischem Wissen für das, was weiß ich, hier der Fehler hat für dieses Nugging, weiß ich nicht, wann ein ähm,
hier im Nobelpreis im Behavera Economics bekommen. So das sind das ist irgendwie Wissen,
wo man weiß, das funktioniert, ja. Letztendlich brauchen wir brauchen wir Dark Patthunce, ja? Im Prinzip muss das so sein, du kommst in so einen Supermarkt, ja und da wird dann kommt so ein Pop-up-Fenster,
und sagt so.
Allen Impfungen.
Alles akzeptieren, alles akzeptieren oder.
Flupp und dann und dann blasrohr zack so ne also mir geht es ja mir geht's ja darum ich will ja ich bin ja nicht also ich wäre als Ultima Ratio nicht gegen eine.
Impfpflicht, aber wenn du sagst, du machst eine Ultima Ratio, dann müsstest du zumindest
sagen, du hast alles versucht. Und wenn man sich die Impfkampagne der deutschen Bundesregierung anschaut,
sich die Impfkommunikation der deutschen Bundesregierung anschaut, wenn man sich anschaut, wie die sich heute noch irgendwie die Hose machen wegen irgendwie zehn Prozent AfD-Idioten
ja, dann ähm kann man einfach sagen, dass die deutsche Impfkampagne gegen,
etabliertes Wissen, wie man Verhalten Gesundheitsverhalten und so weiter steuert, ja. Guck dir das an, also einfaches Beispiel, Apple Watch, ne, sagt dir jede Stunde du sollst mal aufstehen. Ja? Gibt viele Leute, die das deswegen machen.
Ne und das ist einfach, ne, das ist so typisches äh typisches, ne. Dieser äh und.
Könnte die natürlich dich auch äh impfen impfen impfen könnte sie auch machen, aber es ist einfach nicht leicht verfügbar. Ja und wir sehen das ja jetzt gerade, wo wir äh alle um unsere Booster uns bemühen. Wie ähm.
Wie du jetzt doch quasi hier wieder die Traderei anfängt und sagt so ey hier bei der Ärztin kannst du hingehen, die gucken
nicht, ob's fünf Monate sind. Ähm kannst du dich boostern lassen oder was auch immer, ne? Und dieses ähm diese dass es einfach nicht niedrigschwellig ist oder wie in den USA mit diesen Drive-Frou-Impfungen und so. Das hast du in Deutschland einfach nie gesehen
und jedes Mal, wenn es jemand gemacht hat,
so eine schöne Sonntags voll cool die haben hier 150 Leute auf dem was weiß ich auf dem Weihnachtsmarkt geimpft oder sonst was ne und das
diese Verfahren sollte man viel mehr anwenden, weil du möchtest einfach die die Gruppe an Menschen, die du am Ende durch eine Pflicht.
Den wir mit einer Pflicht begegnen musst, die willst du so klein wie möglich halten. So so klein wie nötig. Du willst wirklich vorher alles versucht haben, weil du wirst den Reaktanz-Effekt haben und je größer die Gruppe ist, desto schlimmer ist der.
Also willst du vorher alles mit positiven Anreizen ähm versucht haben.
Um denen, bei denen du das Risiko der Reaktanz eingehst, diese an diese zwei Menschen so so diesen Anteil so klein wie möglich zu haben. Und ich glaube, der ist noch nicht so klein wie möglich.
Ja, also da ist,
jetzt glaube ich auch einen Umschwung äh statt, ne. Äh USA ist natürlich auch wieder ein interessanter Vergleich. Die sind letzten Endes in der Impfquote genauso scheiße wie wir. Also das ist sozusagen da äh da,
da sieht's einfach mal exakt identisch äh aus, obwohl sie das gemacht haben. Es wäre ja wahrscheinlich sonst noch viel schlimmer als bei uns. Aber es ist, wenn man sich halt den Zustand der äh US-amerikanischen Gesellschaft anschaut, auch nicht sonderlich überraschend.
Ist ein Wunder, dass Sie sich überhaupt haben impfen lassen.
Ja, also das ist.
Dass die nicht einfach auf auf Infizierte schießen. Äh das wäre ja vielleicht auch eine gangbare Lösung gewesen für die, ne.
Ja, aber es sind auf jeden Fall dieselben Mechanismen, die die dort äh auch Impfungen verhindern, nur dass die halt noch sehr viel stärker ausgeprägt sind so, ne? Und da sind sie dann eben auch schon ein bisschen aktiver rangegangen. Also
ich finde, wir sind da jetzt grade in so einer interessanten Phase, weil jetzt merkt man eben allein durch dieses Einführen der Impfpflicht in einem deutschsprachigen Land,
ja, weil's halt einfach jetzt an die Grenze geht, die Infektionszahlen Österreich ist halt Deutschland derzeit so im Schnitt um 2 bis3 Wochen voraus,
kann schon gut sein, dass wir hier irgendwie in der übernächsten Sendung schon äh mit ganz anderen Realitäten zu kämpfen haben. Ist noch nicht ganz klar, aber es zeichnet sich auf jeden Fall äh ab, dass da jetzt die Debatte äh härter wird, weil natürlich man sieht jetzt alle
davon schwimmen. Na gut, aber wir müssen jetzt auch keinen Pandemie-Podcast draus machen. Äh letzten Endes äh ist es klar,
ähm diese ganze Zertifikatsgeschichte sehr hm,
Rushed Bar. Ich meine, wir hatten ja am Anfang, äh als das aufkam, hier ein paar Schätzungen abgegeben so nach dem Motto.
Also ich habe wir haben das mal durchgerechnet. Das müsste jetzt eigentlich richtig lange dauern, bis sie das alles nachgeholt haben. Dann ging das schnell
Jetzt zeigt sich halt warum so. Na ja klar, weil halt einfach auch viele Sicherheits äh Faktoren äh schlicht verzichtet wurde und jetzt hat man eben den Salat.
Das wird ein Nee! Nein! Das ist es nicht, Tim! Sorry, ich muss da wirklich widersprechen!
Das ist es auch.
Welchen Sicherheitsmechanismus hättest du denn noch haben wollen? Du musst es,
du du musstest dich darauf ausrichten was weiß ich irgendwie 50, 60 Millionen Menschen in ein paar Monaten durchzuimpfen. Du wolltest einen Impfpass ausrollen. Das ist ein Problem, das kannst du nicht lösen.
Du kannst nur also du kannst nur dort den Impfpass ausstellen lassen wo geimpft wird. Alles andere ist Quatsch,
schon dieses Ausstellen in der Apotheke war Unsinn, war aber notwendig, weil sie eben angefangen hatten zu impfen, ohne einen digitalen Impfpass zu haben,
Wenn du dort die Impfpässe ausstellst, wo du impfst, hast du automatisch es mit ähm ja hunderttausenden zu tun, die diese Impfungen durchführen,
und jeweils wahrscheinlich irgendwo zwischen Faktor 5 und 15,
Menschen, die proimpfende Person, was weiß ich, in der ähm,
der Informationsverwaltung und so weiter assistieren. Ähm entsprechend hast du halt eine Millionen oder mehr Menschen, die in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland in der in der Lage sind äh Impfbescheinigungen auszustellen,
nimmst du eine Korruptionsquote von nur einem Prozent an. Reicht.
Und das ist ein Problem, das kannst du nicht lösen. Das kannst das ist kein technisches Problem. Es ist ein ein eine Sache, die nicht lösbar ist. Ist ein Korruptionsproblem, kein,
und ähm entsprechend, ne oder die Leute spritzen sich Kochsalz, sonstwas. Du du kannst das nicht in den Griff kriegen. Und deswegen musst du ähm,
auch von diesen Impfzertifikaten weg, hin zur Impfung. Ja, wir hätten unabhängig von Impfpässen.
Wollen wir ja gerade Inzidenzen unten halten ja und irgendwie Menschenleben retten und das tun diese Impfpässe nicht. Und wenn du halt nicht die Leute wirklich zu der Impfung motivierst und das hat Deutschland halt wirklich richtig richtig schlecht gemacht.
Kannst froh sein, dass wir überhaupt das überhaupt jemand hat impfen lassen. Und ähm,
ne, die haben überhaupt nicht die Leute sinnvoll motiviert. Ja, ich meine irgendwelche blöden Kampagnen, Ärmel hoch vor Oma oder was, ja, als wenn Kopf, ey.
Komm da hat äh irgendeine Marketingagentur gut bei verdient.
Genau. Da das ist das Problem. Da hätten sie wahrscheinlich besser mit irgendwelchen äh Gesundheitspsychologinnen äh reden können, weil es ist nicht so, als gäbe es nicht.
Wirklich einfach riesige Forschung die dir einfach die dir genau sagen kann wie man so etwas macht und wie nicht,
So, da haben wir Erfahrungen drin. Du kannst jetzt also du kannst heute hingehen und sagen, hä, warum haben wir so eine niedrige Impfung? Er guckt dir guck dir an, wie wir dafür geworben haben. Guck dir an, was für einen Aufwand notwendig war, um dich zu impfen.
Dir an, dass du teilweise Leute für eine Bratwurst geimpft kriegst und,
das haben wir halt nicht ähm nicht gemacht und das ist ein reines ist überhaupt nichts mit diesen Impfpässen zu tun in meiner Wahrnehmung.
Ja also klar. Also der der Impfpass ist ja ist nicht nicht nicht der Schlüssel,
für den Erfolg einer Impfkampagne. Der Schlüssel für den Erfolg einer Impfkampagne ist, wie sie ausgerollt wird und sie ist halt äh sehr zurückhaltend
ausgerollt worden. Klar, man hat am Anfang so die Impfzentren, da hat man gedacht, okay, alles klar, jetzt haben wir ja Impfzentren, dann läuft das alles von alleine. Nur bis zum heutigen Tage äh im 21., 22. Monat dieser Pandemie gab es halt noch nicht eine Postwurfsendung, die mal an die gesamte Postbevölkerung rausging, wo mal drinsteht, was eigentlich hier so die Faktenlage ist.
Soweit ich weiß auch in Österreich nicht jetzt wird's gerade getan ja wurde auch mal Zeit jetzt wird irgendwie umgestellt und dann wird gesagt so ja hier ist ihr Termin so jetzt müssen sie nur noch wahrnehmen so dass man eben auch,
eine andere Ansprache macht an die Leute, ja? Also das werden jetzt spannende Wochen werden, weil ich glaube, ganz ehrlich,
Wenn sich jetzt nichts grundsätzlich ändert in der Herangehensweise.
Dann können wir uns glaube ich auch noch auf eine fünfte und sechste und siebte und achte Welle einstellen. Weil das geht ja dann immer so weiter.
Genau,
Und äh es wäre also wir haben im Prinzip meine meine These, um sie nochmal zusammenzufassen, wir haben hier irgendwie ne den die die wirklich die Speerspitze der ähm,
Na was ist eigentlich? Biotechno de Biotech Forschung mit diesen Impfstoffen, ne? Wir haben da auf alles gehört, was sie äh ähm
Wissenschaft herge äh hatte, ja? Aktuell und wunderbar und richtig geiler Shit, ja.
Aber wir haben halt nicht äh die wissenschaftliche Erkenntnisse äh wohl etablierten wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnisse herangezogen, um dafür zu sorgen, dass wir das auch äh allen zugänglich machen.
Und das heißt, es gibt natürlich immer noch so einen Haufen äh Vollidioten, die wir am Ende mit einem Glasrohr impfen müssen. Ja, das ist klar. Die die haben wir auch. Aber die hoffen eben, dass dass das ein geringer Anteil ist, weil es auch dass auch viel Arbeit, wenn du die,
den Glasrädern das also ich mache das ja schon immer hier bei den äh Querdenker-Demos ne.
Ach du bist das.
Na ja, irgendjemand muss es tun. Es ist ein Höllenjob, ja.
Aber ist wirklich sehr totale Impfbatman.
Äh in Moskau werden jetzt inzwischen die Daten zum Kauf angeboten, von den Leuten, für die die Impfpässe gefälscht wurden.
Geil, das ist Doal Youth, ey. Paar Excellence erst den Leuten irgendwie gefälschte Impfpässe verkaufen und dann gehen die da auch wirklich. Ich meine die die Leute, die so was machen, sind aber auch wirklich so blöd, ne. Also die bezahlen hunderte von Euro.
Irgendwie eine kriminelle Handlung zu begehen bei einem Kriminellen. Dem Kriminellen liefern sie Geburtsdatum und Name freie Haus, ja?
Und am Ende verkaufen die dann auch noch die Information, dass die sich sozusagen gefälschte äh Impfzertifikate geholt haben, verkaufen sie dann auch noch mal Maisbieten wahrscheinlich dann wieder an die Behörden. Also die verdienen sozusagen an jedem Doppelt. Das ist richtig.
Also das äh und das finde ich jetzt äh äh das könnte dann wiederum die Fälscherei aber auch echtes in den Griff kriegen.
Schätze nicht, unterschätze nicht die geschäftstüchtigkeit eines Russen, der ein paar Jahrzehnte in Mangelwirtschaft gelebt hatten.
Ich hoffe, die machen das jetzt in Deutschland auch, weil ich meine, das wäre natürlich dann optimal, weil ich meine, wer sich jetzt äh ne und du sagst ja, hier fälschen äh kann ich unterbunden werden, also wenn man quasi in dem Moment seine Daten abliefert.
Ja, na ja, mal gucken, vielleicht kriegen wir ja den doch noch alle eingesammelt.
Ich will ich also ich wollte jetzt nicht so im Detail drauf eingehen, aber was was passieren also was was möglich ist, wie die Datenverfolgung. Du kannst natürlich, du kannst einen Test drauf machen bei irgendeinem von diesen Telegram-Spinnern,
dann siehst du ja, wie das Ding signiert,
Dann gehst du zu der ähm zu der Signaturbude. Die werden ja nicht in der Arztpraxis signiert, sondern die äh die Signatur dieses Dinges ist ja quasi eine Dienstleistung, die den über ihre Praxissoftware angeboten wird.
Und dann gehst du da hin und sagst, pass auf, welche Praxis war das?
Dann kannst du bei der Praxis potentiell im Patienten spätestens in deren Patientenverwaltungssystem, so sie denn Nutzerinnen-Accounts haben und nicht einfach nur Praxis Praxis?
Oder zumindest die Uhrzeit auch noch miterfassen, ne. Ist das mit drin im Set.
Der ja im Zertifikat steht Datum, Uhrzeit weiß ich nicht genau, aber es würde es ja äh also könntest du auf jeden Fall rausfinden bei der bei der bei dem Signatur Ding,
Genau äh aber ich
wahrscheinlich wird er also eigentlich bei einer Signatur muss ja die Uhrzeit mindestens Datum wahrscheinlich auch die Uhrzeit und äh in der Praxis, also ich habe mir das in einer Praxis genauer angeschaut in der Praxis, spätestens in der Praxis könntest du halt sehen, ah okay, es war diese Mitarbeiterin, die das Ding ausgestellt hat.
In anderen, bei anderen Praxen, die halt keine Trennung nach äh Benutzern haben, könntest du immerhin den Tag sehen.
Und ähm du könntest dann ähm
quasi bei mehreren eben äh wahrscheinlich relativ schnell eingrenzen, wer wann wo da war, ne. Oder du kannst eventuell auch sehen, von welchem Rechner oder sonst was, ne? Und dann
Jetzt ist aber die Frage, nehmen wir mal das dieses Beispiel Praxis? So, die.
Eine mögliche Konsequenz wäre jetzt alle Impfzertifikate von dieser Praxis ungültig zu machen. Das ginge.
Viel Spaß für die ganzen Leute, denen dann jetzt die Impfzertifikate devalidiert wurden,
Ja? Und die jetzt hingehen und sagen, na ja, ich wurde nun mal geimpft, was soll ich denn machen.
Weil die Praxis hat ja potenziell auch tatsächlich geimpft. Und jetzt kannst du den Unterschied nicht feststellen.
So und dann komm komm ich und sag hör mal Leute äh mein Impfpass ist nicht mehr gültig, weil ihr Deppen äh irgendwelche Identitätrahmen gemacht habt,
Aber ich wurde bei euch geimpft oder habt ihr mir auch irgendwie Kochsalzlösungen oder Ivan McQueen oder wat auch immer Chlor, Chlor,
geimpft, ja? Und dann sagen die, ja, hm, Scheiße. Tut uns leid, muss die Nummer, muss die noch mal woanders impfen lassen. Sage ich, ja, mich impft aber keiner, weil
Weil äh wenn ich denen sage, dass ich schon geimpft bin, ne, also so wenn das Ding einmal das Problem einmal in der Welt ist, kannst du maximal
einzelne Zertifikate nochmal devalidieren aber dass da am Ende wirklich jemand eine Strafe kriegt außer die die es gemacht haben und das da setzt die Strafe ja an.
Die Straferei, es reicht ja jetzt vermutlich ein Testkauf, damit du halt in den Knast wanderst. Und das sollte im Zweifelsfall diese Telegram-Leute ähm zum Überdenken.
Ihrer Geschäftspraxis oder äh auch zum ähm wenn sie's nicht überdenken zur unfreiwilligen Einstellung ihrer Geschäftspraxis bringen. Das ist schon klar, ja. Das das wird so sein.
Aber die die die bereits ausgestellten wird wird nichts passieren.
Hätte man filigraner die äh Zertifikate verteilen müssen.
Hätte man ich glaube tatsächlich also mein Schluss daraus ist, das hättest du nicht anders lösen können und du
wirst
also du wirst diese illegitime Ausstellung nicht unterbinden können. Du kannst sie halt unter hohe Strafen stellen in Ordnung, aber du kannst auch äh das die andere Möglichkeit wäre gewesen, so wenig Motivation dafür aufzubauen, wie es geht und durch negative Anreize,
baust du die Motivation auf und das ist schlecht.
Also ich bin eher die äh Abteilung äh all of the baff, also ist richtig was du sagst, aber trotzdem äh hätte man bei den Zertifikaten da noch die äh Schrauben bisschen äh besser anziehen können, dass es halt nicht erfolgt, sondern insofern haben wir den äh Salat, aber ich glaube.
Aber wie denn? Wo denn? Wo willst du dir denn noch mehr anziehen? Also sorry, eher ernsthaft wo?
Dem halt äh diese Zertifikate sehr viel ähm feinkörniger äh zertifiziert werden als das äh derzeit ist.
An welcher Stelle denn? Von wem denn.
Dass so die ausstellende Person da sozusagen auch äh quasi ein eigenes Zertifikat äh hat in dem.
Ach so äh ja also das das ist
also mein Verständnis ist, das äh mögen wir bitte korrigiert werden, dass äh dass das zwar nicht im Zertifikat steht, aber natürlich diese Intermediaries, die die Zertifikate für andere ausstellen, diesen Nachweis durch durchaus noch erhalten.
Ja, aber das ist.
Also dass das nicht im Zertifikat steht, sondern bei den Signaturstellen äh festgehalten wird und da sollte ja reichen.
Genau, also das hätte man schon noch machen können und es hätte halt nur den logistischen Rollout,
signifikant verzögert und das war natürlich in der Situation nicht leistbar und deswegen hat man jetzt ein System, bei dem es einfach,
nachträglich extrem schwieriges einzelne Zertifikate oder einzelne Zertifikatsaussteller äh feinkörnig rauszunehmen, ohne gleich sehr vielen Leuten sehr viel Ärger zu machen.
Ist ja noch schlimmer. Die haben ja jetzt erst die haben die das Gesundheitsministerium, hat Impfzertifikat-Revocation ja erst vor Kurzem in Auftrag gegeben.
War ja spezifisch, die haben ja quasi also zu all diesen Leuten auch irgendwie lose Kontakte. Ich habe ja auch einen Kontakt zu äh den Leuten, die den ähm hier Koffpass-Check und so gebastelt haben, ja.
Gesagt, wie sieht's aus mit Revocation? Haben die gesagt, ja hätten wir äh gerne gemacht.
Ne stand aber nicht im Auftrag.
Haben die gekürzt? Haben die rausgenommen, brauchen.
Na ja ich meine man man lernt da so. Ich meine ich habe jetzt mal äh auf den Impfpass äh geschaut. Ich habe ja jetzt auch meine Booster äh Impfung mir abgeholt. Du ja auch und äh ich weiß nicht, wie das bei dir ist, aber
dritte Runde war jetzt irgendwie moderner und während halt die ersten beiden Runden noch so dieser normale weiße Aufkleber war äh hat zumindest der jetzt einen Barcode,
Also so ein so ein so ein so ein 2D äh Code, kein QR-Code, sondern ich weiß nicht, wie heißt dieser andere Code.
Nein, nein, also auch ein quadratischer Pixelcode, aber halt nicht der QR-Code, den wir alle kennen.
Ist ja auch egal, dieser andere ähm weiß nicht genau wie der heißt, zwei Deko, sondern ich gucke gerade mal, ob.
Den kann jetzt keiner fälschen.
Äh das habe ich nicht gesagt, aber das ist zumindest äh eine eine scannbare Information mit einer äh Chargenummer oder sowas. Ähm ich habe aber jetzt gerade nicht den passenden äh Scanner dafür, um den irgendwie zu scannen.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob das wirklich ein Sicherheitsfeature ist, aber da ändert sich auf jeden Fall was.
Ja, aber das äh na ja, sorry, also die resultierende Sicherheit wird sich dadurch nicht ändern, ja und äh es gibt noch genug Ärztinnen. Also ich gucke mal, es gibt da draußen Ärzte, die die haben grade.
Des Pferdeentwurmungsmittel ausverkauft.
Die armen Pferdealter, die die Pferde krepieren jetzt an Würmern, weil irgendwelche Covidioten, denen das das Entwurmungsmittel wegsaufen.
Ciao.
So
Lass uns das Thema jetzt äh an der Stelle abschließen. Ich glaube, ist alles dazu gesagt. Sonst wird's noch albern.
So äh ich habe ein äh Vorwort für ein Buch geschrieben. Ja, das gibt's auch schon seit Längerem. Ich habe das.
Sozusagen.
Ja
Und zwar ist es ein Buch, das ähm von artical nine Teen, Artikel Nintine ist so eine ja eine NGO so im Internetbereich,
also im äh Internet rechte Netzpolitik-Bereich und äh die haben ein Buch geschrieben.
Äh das hieß glaube ich der Originaltitel ist glaube ich äh how the Internet really works and illustrated guy to protocolds privacy sensarship and governments.
Und äh die deutsche Übersetzung davon ist sehr schön illustriert, wirklich ein schönes Buch. Und die deutsche Übersetzung davon ist erschienen im,
D-Punkt-Verlag und die haben mich äh gefragt, ob ich für das Buch Das Internet gehört uns allen, Protokolle, Datenschutz Zensur,
Internet Governance anschaulich illustriert. Ähm ob ich dafür ein Vorwort schreibe.
Habe ich gemacht und da wird so alles drin erklärt, ne, wie was ist eigentlich TCP, IP-Rooting und da haben sie so eine hauptsächlich ja so Katzen sind das, die das größtenteils dann da,
illustrieren sehr schön also es ist wie jedes Bild jede Seite mit sehr vielen Illustrationen und ähm ja ich denke,
Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, ich kenne mich mit Kindern nicht so gut aus, aber ähm das wird man sicherlich spätestens Jugendlichen,
geben können. Ich kann mal hier gerade gut kurz auf der Seite des Verlags schauen. Richtet sich an. Alle die digitale Kompetenz erlangen,
vermitteln möchten, okay, weil's also ich glaube, das kann man auf jeden Fall ähm wir sagen also von neun bis neunundneunzig ähm ist dieses Buch geeignet und wir verlinken das mal in den,
Shownotes. Ich habe da den Link direkt zum Verlag D Punkt, ja, die ähm.
Dieses Buch vertreiben, wenn man es dort kauft, haben die da auch am ehesten etwas von. Ich habe gerade noch mal extra,
Verlag äh gefragt. Also bitte dort kaufen. Kostet äh sechzehn neunundneunzig. Bei Lieferung in Nicht-EU-Länder können,
Oder Gebühren entstehen. Genau, ist am 25.1. entschieden, erschienen 124 Seiten und ähm das Vorwort werde ich wahrscheinlich auch nochmal als Blogpost,
veröffentlichen.
Aber warum soll man's denn dann noch kaufen? Wenn du das einfach äh in das Internet, Raubmord kopierst.
Wegen des des Inhalts des Buches ich bin mir noch nicht mal sicher, ob das nicht sogar eh äh ähm irgendwo als als E-Book auch ähm.
Sowieso frei zugänglich ist oder so. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Was versteht denn hier den Copyright für die Deutsch Sprüche, doch hat es gibt Copy.
Urheberrechtlich geschützt. Nee, also ist nicht nicht frei verfügbar. Also kann man aber kaufen und äh ist tatsächlich ganz ein ganz nettes Buch, wo das sehr schön äh mal so erklärt ist.
Ja? Würde ich wirklich sagen. Ähm also Empfehlung habe ich auch nichts von.
Außer, dass ich das, dass, dass ich sagen kann, wenn ich einen Vorbot schreibe, wird das Buch gekauft.
Kann man auf jeden Fall sich mal also denke ich so wenn man so die netzpolitische Einführung, Internet wie ist das so ähm.
Ach so und wenn man hier D Punkt Plus Mitglied ist, dann kriegt man auch ein PDF, wie auch immer.
Ist in den Shownotes verlinkt, empfiehlt sich wahrscheinlich als äh Geschenk an an Jugendliche oder Rentner oder an sich selber.
So und dann haben wir noch einen kleinen äh einen kleinen Link in den in den auf den ich aufmerksam wurde durch äh Jens Kubitzil äh auf Twitter und zwar eine,
fragt den Staat eine IFG-Anfrage an das niedersächsische Kultusministerium relativ kurz gehalten.
Also die von irgendjemand irgendjemand eingereicht wurde über über das Portal.
Genau, bei frag den Staat. Wir können ja frag den Staat. Ja das ist und zwar ist das die Anfrage,
2hundertdreißig, zweihundertsechzig, äh verletzte Kippler in Schulen an, das niedersächsische Kultusministerium, hallo in unserer Schule, bekommen wir immer Ärger. Wenn wir mit den Stühlen kippen, weil es gefährlich ist.
Wie viele Schüler haben sich verletzt, weil sie in der Schule gekippelt haben? So,
Also, da wurde also hier äh die äh die Frage gestellt, äh bitte senden Sie mir folgendes zu, wurde dann hier von frag den Staat nochmal kolgi. So, jetzt haben Sie
äh jetzt hat das äh Kultusministerium geantwortet. Zu ihrer nachstehenden Anfrage kann ich Ihnen leider keine Auskunft erteilen, ja.
Sie äh äh berufen sich hier aus formalen Gründen und so weiter nicht einschlägig. Äh wir haben diese Informationen nicht,
Darüber hinaus gibt es in Niedersachsen keine Rechtsnorm für einen allgemeinen Zugang zu behördlichen Informationen, anderes gilt nur für Personen, die persönlich betroffen sind und zum Beispiel als Verfahrensbeteiligte ein spezifisches Interesse haben und so weiter.
Um ihn dennoch im Rahmen meiner Möglichkeiten zu helfen, weise ich sie darauf hin, dass sie Informationen zu ihrer Fragestellung gegebenenfalls bei den Trägern der gesetzlichen Schüler
Unfallversicherung erhalten können. Mir persönlich ist aus Presse veröffentlicht, zumindest ein tragischer Fall bekannt, bei dem ein Schüler beim
Kippeln gegen eine Heizung gefallen ist und an den Folgen der Verletzung verstorben ist mit freundlichen Grüßen.
Wurde wenigstens ernsthaft äh beantwortet.
Muss ich sagen, hat sich jemand äh richtig äh reingeworfen.
Als äh Kommunikationsprofi will ich den Schülern natürlich jetzt das Präventionsparadox erklären. Das Dank der äh ne dank der allgemeinen Nicht-Kippe-Pflicht in deutschen Schulen.
Wahrscheinlich tausende von Schülern schon gerettet.
Tausende von Schülern gerettet wurden und dann würden die Schüler wahrscheinlich die Querkippler gründen. Und dann nimmt das alles seinen Lauf.
Schaufelt. Euer eigenes Grab.
Okay. Aber ich fand's ganz schön. Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall sieht man jetzt, dass das auch Kinder äh jetzt mal langsam sagen so äh wir würden gerne Daten sehen. Show me the Data. Das ist doch schon mal gut. Das.
Ja, das ist ganz gut. Da haben sie ja bekommen. Dann kann man auch da mal ordentlich drüber diskutieren. Ist doch gar nicht so schlecht.
Ja, das war's so aus dem Internet für diese Woche.
Ja, ich denke auch, das war jetzt ausreichend ausführlich. Leute, insofern äh entlassen wir euch in den nächsten Lockdown. Was auch immer jetzt kommen mag. Ähm,
dann hören wir uns nächste Woche wieder.
Also ich Lockdown, also ich glaube, ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob ich mir nochmal einen gefallen lassen würde.
Du bist ja auch geimpft oder?
Ich bin hier dreifach geimpft und ähm ich kann das belegen und äh ich würde ähm.
Belegen. Ja. Mit was denn? Mit was denn?
Ich habe ein Video wie ich mir den selber ausstelle.
Muss mich ja mit der Praxistechnik bekannt machen. Nein, Quatsch. Die ähm äh also ich habe ja äh also.
Sehr.
Kommst du gleich zu den Schleudern.
Nee, ich bin sehr, ich habe mich ja äh zu Beginn des Jahres sehr stark eben auch gegen jene äh ausgesprochen, die halt verfrüht.
Bevorteiligung für Geimpfte verlangt haben zu Zeiten, zu denen einfach ganz klar war, dass Leute noch nicht alle, die wollten geimpft wurden und ich habe den Eindruck, dass dieser äh Moment.
Ähm dann doch jetzt bald erreicht ist, ja? Dass sie jetzt niemanden mehr sitzt und sagt
Boah Alter ey seit Januar warte ich auf die Impfung. Ich will endlich ne das ist einfach ne das war ja auch die Impfzentren wurden ja nicht geschlossen weil Jens Spahn die Pandemie beenden wollte, sondern weil die halt nicht mehr den Durchzug hatten.
Ähm und.
Ich denke, also ne, ich stehe dem nicht nicht äh ablehnend gegenüber, äh vor allem, wenn es jetzt hier irgendwelche Lockdowns gibt,
sehe ich nicht ein, warum ihr mich von irgendwelchen AfD-Querdenkern wieder in meine Zimmer sperren lassen soll, nur weil die Vollidioten sich da draußen aufführen wie sonst wäre, aber,
ist all das, ich bleibe dabei, wird nur die die Fälschungsquote hochzerren und das ist alles nicht schön. Alles nicht schön.
Ja, fand ich auch sehr schön, als es dann irgendwie in Sachsen jetzt äh loseskaliert ist letzte Woche und dann schon so die ersten äh 2G äh Maßnahmen dann beschlossen wurden, so dann,
haben sie die Fernsehkameras in die in die Warteschlange im im Einkaufszentrum, wo so äh ambulant geimpft wurde, reingehalten und die Leute fragen, ja sie stehen ja hier alle jetzt an und so
Warum lassen sich denn also was was ist denn der Grund, dass sie sich jetzt hier impfen lassen und so. Ja ist voll wichtig irgendwie. Also man muss ja unbedingt geimpft sein.
Mal so mehr als eine Person und dachte mir nur so, Leute guckt mal auf die Uhr. Es ist jetzt irgendwie also.
Ja, aber du musst wissen, das ist.
Euch sollte die Schamesröte im Gesicht stehen jetzt irgendwie, wenn ihr dazu befragt werdet, aber dann so rumzuargumentieren, als wär's gerade März und der äh äh ihr seid so die Ersten, die sich äh äh auf den Zug stürzen so. Das das geht auch irgendwie echt gar nicht.
In in in Sachsen gibt's ja die freien Sachsen. Ne, also du kannst dir ungefähr vorstellen welchen intellektuellen Hintergrund die haben.
Und die haben ja jetzt mitbekommen, dass in Österreich die Impfpflicht angekündigt wurde und die fordern jetzt Asyl.
Viel Erfolg damit.
Dass die nochmal Asyl fordern, fördern, fordern für für irgendjemanden.
Impfasylanten tja.
Das ist so so bitter, weißt du? Du findest so wenn du das Buch vor einem Jahr geschrieben hättest, hättest du gesagt, so, komm, Alter, völlig übertrieben, hör mal auf, ey. Wer soll das denn lesen?
Ist doch doch total unrealistisch.
Aber so läuft's halt. Das ist äh das ist das Problem.
Okay. Damit ähm lassen wir euch zurück ins Internet.
Ja, genau. Viel Spaß da. Da steht immerhin die Wahrheit drin.
Ciao ciao.